and we are live ready for the junior speed chess
champion final i am grand master robert hess and
of course alongside me today as usual is grand
master daniel diskey donya we have a thriller in
the making between mihal sarin and alexis serrano
what are you expecting from today's final match
robert a pleasure to be doing
this again uh for the last time
the stage is set for an incredible showdown both
of these players are amazing in and of themselves
they have also survived trial after
trial challenge after challenge
and they have made it to the finals against each
other alexis arana and nihal saren i am expecting
the most thrilling match yet robert and that is
saying a lot because we have seen some pretty
darn thrilling matches already we certainly have
and if we you know bring up the smarter chess
predictions brought to us by chess goals in this
final between nihal sereno alexis saranac it's
going to be a pretty you know balanced matchup
but you see the final prediction down there
14 to 12 in nielsen's favor 63 win probability
and interestingly enough sarnath has the
edge i would say in the longer time controls and
he showed that he evidenced that against jeffrey
chong in the semi-final right he just was dominant
in the earlier stages despite having some shaky
positions he did uh and he showed some superb
opening preparation and he showed uh incredible
ability to adjust to different time controls but
uh nihal is nihal we all know of his prowess in
all time controls his ratings reflect that and
he has played incredibly in all matches so far
uh he's just a force to be reckoned with but this
is i don't even know what to say these are both
such beasts for sure let's uh remind everybody
of the overall bracket to see how they got there
nihal knocked up andrew tang who qualified
his way in then beat anton smirnoff and
it was a pretty close matchup and then looked
dominant against hike marching rose and that was
probably the most surprising result in the entire
bracket and on the other side of things alexis
saranac he beats his compatriot andre issapenko
then takes down the americans sevien and zhang
and now he's facing off against nihal sarin so
i mean anything surprising there i feel like
we just come to express expect excuse me it's a
success we have but if if you remember it's crazy
panko is already a monster and to beat him in the
first rounds not to mention you know the other two
matchups and the same of course goes for nihal i
mean these players faced uh incredible opposition
in the very first matchup not to mention uh the
next stages so uh to be able to win time and time
again dominant performances against zhang against
marturosian are are incredible i mean dominant
performances of any kind against the best of the
best here in the jscc are always so impressive
certainly the case and you know for sarina in
particular he beat higher rated feta classical
opposition i mean yes panko is like 26 80 70
somewhere around 26.70 jefferson over 2700 so did
he beat anyone good you know just some slackers
here and there and we do have liftoff d4 played by
nihal and one thing i'm going to be keeping
my eye on is the speed because neil has a
tendency to spend a bit too much time in the early
stages of the game whereas whereas sarana was just
a speedster against jeffrey john he was always
up on time and opening preparation is going
to be extremely important in this match
because that is what saranac is known for
and nihal is going to have to show but
obviously not that nihal is not known for that
so play very quickly in the
opening yeah what is this line here
wow take that e4 and then the bishop was
hanging on a6 yeah i've seen this somewhere
i don't know these lines i can understand what
they're doing but if we just back up a second
here the point was that after knight takes g5 if
then i want to capture queen takes g7 can happen
hitting the knight hitting the rook and the king
is going to be caught in the center probably to a
deadly attack so that's why black didn't go scoop
off this bishop over here instead we saw a castle
and after queen takes were a6 if that knight moves
out the way down goes the bishop one g5 and then
that's why white castles and goes for an attack
on the king's side so dania black is up a pawn for
the time being that b5 is quite weak as is c3 and
is that still must be some kind of theory because
nihal is moving instantly yeah probably some like
bashiela grab you know aronian game from 2017
uh you think you know wow this is a crazy
line and then you see like 18 super level
games from you know norway chess or i don't know
why i'm out of nowhere chess but you know one of
those tournaments uh where you know pretty decent
players are playing normally like magnus uh man
can we compensate some actual players robert
but in any case yeah so i used to actually
play the vienna for black which is what this is
called i mean i don't know the ins and outs of
it i don't remember anything what i do know is
that white has now restored material equality
but black has restored proper development for his
pieces i think white's got the edge though if you
look at that e5 pawn it's under some pressure
you don't want to take on c6 prematurely but
you can play rook fp1 and i think white is the one
pressing on the gas pedal here for the time being
yeah i'm with you there an action an interesting
move that i was thinking about said f3 was bishop
to f4 because i'm trying to take on c6 and
you can't move the pawn but i understand that
it's a little bit too much uh you can't just
go and get away with things like this often
i can protect the bishop like rook f6 and that way
i can take your bishop when you take my knight so
getting fancy could backfire it could also work
out sometimes but uh he went and said f3 and
rook a to d1 so a little bit of a tamer approach
right and bishop b3 now the rook shifts over to
e1 having misplaced the bishop king to h8 uh
getting the king out of the potential danger
zone and i think king h1 getting the king out
of the potential danger zone and i did do you
see that twice in a row i'm just making sure that
i heard that i did say that i did say that twice
in a row but now i think that um nihal can try
to well the battle revolves around the e5 pawn
and whether or not nihal will be able to put
sufficient pressure on it the game could also
fizzle out in some kind of a draw yeah it's
interesting that in this position black has the
better center white has the bishop pair and this
bishop on b3 you have to be a bit careful not to
leave it there too long because if c4 happens and
i can follow up with an attack on that bishop it
could get trapped over there however c4 does
free up the d4 square for this black knight
and that's why that pawn is going to remain on
c3 for the time being and dino rook came to d6
yeah i have this feeling that you know nihal will
try his best to apply more pressure in the center
but i could see this game turning from what i
consider white's favor into black's favor if that
center can expand eventually an e4 type of move
at the right moment that can open up the position
and i feel like you have to be ready for it all
times yeah queen f2 comes to mind here's something
to that effect preparing yourself against e4
which does open up the f file i mean of course
you didn't necessarily mean immediately i i agree
i mean there's a lot of things that white has to
watch out for in particular that center um and and
white has has to decide how he's going to arrange
his thesis is he going to go for c4 or is he going
to go let's say queen f2 queen c5 is that proposed
or is he going to go i don't know bishop c1
bishop i mean there's a lot of these maneuvers
that exist and are out there in the ether but
you have to kind of pick one and stick with it
and that can be difficult for sure another one
i'll throw out is bishop h4 bishop g3 is sort of
standard rerouting of the bishop you can start
with bishop f4 to go to g3 just because this
pawn e5 is pinned for the time being to the
rook on e8 so white has many different options
and nihal now is a little bit behind on the clock
because he's spending his time here i personally
i would be in the same boat i would be thinking
which of these options will work out best for
me and i i don't know bishop h4 h4 has that ring
to it because it attacks the e5 yeah so i i think
putting the bishop on g3 makes just a lot of sense
here right and um this is a critical moment i
think it's understandable why nihal is taking his
time here uh this you know it always seems weird
to say that this moment could decide the game
but again i i think when you're analyzing a game
you come back always to these types of critical
moments and either you celebrate the decision
making are you saying man you know i rushed
or i didn't pay attention to the right things
and here i think neal's just spending too much
time because he's what a minute and a half or so
here i can see it now he just made the movie
h3 two minutes he spent two minutes on the move
h3 and even though that's a perfectly fine move
he just now is in a hole in the clock he's down
a full minute and we've seen sarnath match after
match give him a lead on the clock he continues to
put pressure on his opponent then when there is a
time scramble he often is the one who comes out on
top however we of course have to acknowledge nihal
is an absolute machine in bullet chest if anyone
can get out of a position with mere seconds on
this clock it is him yeah i'm still thinking about
his uh display uh i mean several bullet displays
uh which have been just absolutely marvelous i
mean the speed the the accuracy the intuition
uh but yeah we've seen serrano particularly in
the last match as you said put pressure on the
opponent uh when when he's got 50 40 seconds on
the clock and here's all dipping into his clock
again queen to a5 attacking c3 another decision
to be made for white this is what sarah and i is
really good at making forcing his opponent uh to
make decisions i would say queen e3 comes to mind
queen e3 queen c5 another idea um perhaps nihal
is considering bishop g3 and after queen takes it
while he plays it after queen takes e3 bishop c6
maybe restore material balance i'm not sure
about this something about this seems a little
bit off-road yeah because the rook on e8 and
there's a queen on e2 and the rook typically wins
the battle but he says wait a sec let me just
steal your a4 i wasn't even looking at the a4
that was kind of obvious in retrospect yeah i
know who was uh lexi was and but done it's kind
of obvious in retrospect that pawn is hanging
now that he took it but it's like wait isn't
you take on c6 with your bishop and after bishop
takes e5 you can put your rook on e6 and that will
force white to move the pawn to f4 that's a really
big deal because just to show something like this
is if you have to play f4 c3 there's a problem
down on g2 it's for this rook to come to g6 in the
future and just like the bishop one e5 looks very
good uh the bishop one c6 as a quincy there's a
very nice move that you spotted because the queen
is not defended on e2 enough times yeah the queen
takes h3 as a threat there geez so rookie six
played f4 and then i yeah i'll take on c3 here
you know just one nice tactical sequence that
works out in sarno's favor and he doesn't have to
i mean he's got pressure on g2 that he could mount
but uh you know the opportunity train doesn't come
along twice in terms of such a pawn uh or as
as grandmaster alexander o'neil once told me
you know free puns don't just lie on the side of
the road and he said that as a metaphor because i
was refuting refusing the oars or dovers at
the opening ceremony of the us championship
and you know there were just
sandwiches lying there and he said
three pawns don't fly on the side of the road and
i immediately picked up a sandwich and started
you took that wise you know the why saying they're
of a wonderful grandmaster and i was in honor
hey donna you you know you saw queen c3 sarna
follows your lead here and king issue what do
you make of that decision to get the queens on the
board you know trading off i think would have been
bad because the rook lends an e2 which is too
much activity for black but if we think bigger
picture if you could just take the queens off
the board as they are right now does that help
white or black black because of partly because of
the time situation because he gets a blank check
when it comes to just making attempts and that
g2 pawn is if the rook lands on e2 white's rook
is going to be saddled to g1 i mean we've talked
about this before opposite colored bishops yes but
the rooks on the board lend the game a far more
combative character than if they had been alone
what i also liked about nihal's decision starting
out is a minute and you know you mentioned that
you could see the game turning in black's favor
earlier and it did i can see the game strangely as
the sounds turning into turning to white's favor
potentially because of that g7 pawn particularly
if white lifts his rook from e3 to g3 yeah that
looks like a very easy plan to execute for me
neoliberal black is up at pawn but it's irrelevant
for the time being that b-pawn is not pushing with
so much material on the board so i think that
sargon has to figure out a way to save his king
the f5 pawn is under attack so maybe queen f8 king
h7 g6 but it does feel risky to push this g pawn
because then your dark squares are permanently
open does it yeah this is i i feel like there it
goes king h7 that's exactly what he does and
here comes g6 yeah i mean he doesn't well he
could play rookie 7 but yeah that g6 now the queen
drops to d1 and as you said robert the diagonal
has opened up i don't know who's i mean
practically speaking i don't know who's better now
sarnath has dipped on the clock yeah saran time
trouble himself in fact nihal is ahead and that
i think bodes well for white's chances you made
the point that you could see this turning around
it just feels like a position where black's king
is in worse shape than whites because the pawn g2
is defended while this rook on g3 is attacking
g6 you know it's protecting g2 but how to make
progress from here that's a totally different
question because you can't play h4h5 the h4 square
is covered by uh black's queen and he plays king
to h1 that's an odd yeah it steps back into the
pin i mean you could play king h2 i don't think
that well okay rookie what he's really sort of
you know crouching and digging himself
this is a little bit odd from from neil
now h5 star not bouncing rook to d3 trying to
trade rooks okay i think that's a bit of an
odd sequence yeah i think you just want to trade
a pair of rooks that's what nihal was focused on
with the queen trade being offered oh it
could have traded queens i thought that in
ending without the queens would have been pretty
easy to hold but he says your king on h7 is still
very weak here he might be playing for a win
yeah that's brave that's definitely it is
but if he plants the queen on g5 okay
he's coming okay b5 softens up the bishop
sir arnold doesn't want to do that that's
a big concession and queen d8 is nice to
also stop something kind of queen g5 right okay
okay that may be rook cafe now that is another
committal move okay daniel i see there's a
tactical sequence there that i'll show after
the game you know in that rook 8 but i just whoa
g3 check watch out for a back rank check maybe
but black's also got to watch both kings
of five seconds for both of them here we go
we need six to go to h3 oh you oh no okay
trick quincy two queens you do immediately
oh what a turnaround and nihal gets it oh my wow
goodness oh we have to look at that that is crazy
and i want to see your sequence as well all right
let's go back to the analysis board to bring up
the game that just finished uh so that's it oops
sorry bring up this yeah the one sequencing you
know you're talking about this rook a8 move and
right here if rook a8 rook f8 i thought there was
some kind of queen g5 but there's not like queens
trying to like take on f8 and meet you back here
but unfortunately after queen g5 queen takes the
g2 pawn is hanging with mate first my whole idea
was distract your queen and take your rook and say
hey your queen's under attack and i'm meeting you
but of course g2 that would have worked actually
had the pawn been on g3 for example yes if the
palmer up one square that would have worked but
sadly it doesn't with the pawn g2 and towards the
end of this game danya it looked like black was
the one trying to play for a win but rook d8 came
and he just was winning for black it was winning
oh my gosh queen takes e5 365 is winning back
and it comes all of us i mean because sarah and
i was paying attention to that h3 square uh as
as were we but uh wow what incredible incredible
stuff and it said you found the checkmate the king
was ensnared by white's pieces and that was that
let's go to the second game because that one is in
full swing and there's a pawn on g4 so i i look
like a normal position somehow the queen on d5
but then i saw white's pawn is on g4 so the knight
cannot capture the queen it is pinned but you can
either capture the queen directly or capture this
bishop so you can capture the queen next move
it's a very common type of idea but i think the
intermental queen takes before there is no queen
f3 because queen takes f8 so what do you think
about this queen takes bishop move down there um
it's i mean i like the two bishops personally i
think that it can be easier to play with the two
bishops but there are certain squares that the
knights can jump to and he goes bishop d2 now
decision for black does he take the queen and
go let's say knight a5 and go after that pawn
again i'm sure that this is still theory or
queen a5 is the other i think option in my
eyes uh knight takes d4 doesn't work because of
queen takes queen actually that would have been
uh somewhat that would have led to some wild
complications but but that doesn't work for black
so i think the real decision is between queen a5
and queen takes c3 we take b3 yeah i just want to
point out that you were looking at this d4 square
so many tactics flying in this position yes the
black queen is under attack but you're putting an
attacker on the queen on b3 but instead he takes
and was rooked to d8 and if you try to analyze
this position you know full picture if we just
started trying to talk about descriptively black's
pawn structure is definitely better but white's
bishop on f1 in particular has the option to
take over the board compared to this bishop on
c8 so has bishop d7 bishop c6 a potential
idea maybe i don't maybe okay c5
but does that really fully let black escape
from some of the potential problems because
it's kind of like a catalan type of position
right there's always going to be pressure on
the queen side that's right on the money that
catalan reference because sometimes you play
c5 you take a deep breath i finally liberated
myself from the troubles but that bishop on g2
in combination with some of the other squares
on the queen side he goes c6 so he takes a more
sort of uh passive bunker style approach which
is interesting because the bishop on g2 is is now
blunted by the pawn sarina has more active pieces
but i think nihal is going to be asking him well
how exactly do you make progress i'm going to
put my knight on d5 potentially put my pawn on a6
what is white going to do uh in order to progress
here yeah you if you play e4 you have to be very
careful because that loosens up your defense of
the d4 pawn i think you can probably get away
with it right now but just as a sample line e4
knight c7 the d4 pawn is already under attack
and a bishop e3 there's knight to b5 hitting your
pin knight and hitting your palm in the center so
you have to be really careful before you push
this e pawn because it does make this deep on
like an immediate target right and uh that
can be a useful tool in a blitz game rubber
by the way this idea there's a move that you can
play on any move and on every move you have to
consider playing it but you never know when to
play uh so that takes away and that was a very
convoluted sentence but that takes away a lot
of time and i like what tsarnaev is doing here
connecting his rooks and uh there's a lot of
improvements that he can make without playing
right he could actually play f4 he can play g5
if he wants to if for some reason kicking this
knight away feels correct but he can just start
expanding and black is really passive here yeah b6
your bishop was going to b7 a5 bishop a6 though
that is a much better plan indeed because the
king on e2 is not exactly in the safest of
positions right now that's taking advantage
of your opponent's decision to keep having
having played knee hall and blitz games he's
incredibly good at this kind of defense uh and and
he generates chances but but it's not just cheap
tricks it's actual annoying defensive attempts and
that's exactly what you have to do in a position
like this you don't go for the full nine yards
immediately you go for a little bit of activity
you breathe some nervousness in your opponent and
then you go from there yeah for sure and i mean
look at what sauron just did he went knight d3
a couple moves ago and then brought his knight
right back to e5 and it feels like he's wavering
a bit trying to figure out how to prevent black's
a5 bishop of a6 you pointed out that idea it's a
very good one and he takes on d5 so interesting
transition dania where you take on d5 you have
the worst queenside pawn structures but your
rook on h1 is very quickly coming to c1 and your
rook on a1 perfectly placed hitting the a7 block
right and we indeed see this transformation in the
pawn structure bishop d6 to cover that c7 square
and yes the position has transformed uh i don't
think this is an unwelcome transformation for
for nihal especially if he can smoke that knight
out of e5 yeah i think the only way you can really
smoke it out is by capturing it because this
knight can go to c6 at some moment just taking
advantage of the fact that there's a vulnerable
light square and it's a fiance bishop but it's
not a pawn so in comes the knight b5 of course is
an idea for sarah knott push that one forward to
cement control of that square and you know anytime
you take on e5 you're doubling white's pawns
but you're giving up more control the c file in
particular this c7 square so dania i don't think
you're going to take on e5 yeah no something tells
me it's a little bit too too committal he goes a6
and he sets up a barricade stopping b4
b5 well you know what he walks into right
is knight c4 because your bishop on b7 is
not defending no you did bishop c7 knight
right because i'm attacking your bishop and your
pawn bishop c7 looks like it defends both but
knight a5 and your bishop is under attack down in
the c5 both your sharp today he goes g5 instead
that could be helping black in the event of knight
d7 right and knight d7 that will protect the pawn
on b6 very importantly because this knight
c4 tactic uh is a nuisance because precisely
that pawn is left undefended and i think that this
knight c4 idea you should always be on the lookout
when bishops are staring each other down and what
happens if the piece in between them is removed
and that's why knight c4 it's a relatively common
tactic in certain variations uh so i was just
keeping an eye on that but done it so now that he
has not played knight to c4 i guess he can play
it if this knight but the knight really is only
two squares or unless you take an e5 first which
perhaps you can consider you can but i i
don't think so i i would not part ways of
that bishop which is holding together the
c7 square i think he is deciding between
98 and 97 because 98 has also the benefit
and then you can play f6 he does go 97
uh taking this thing out of knight c4 again he can
go f6 here or he can delay it um you could go b5
conceivably but that is a very responsible move i
don't like that because that weakens the knight e3
that b5 move just is asking for it giving
connections right right exactly and this is
the good thing about the double pawns is that
b5 knight b6 is always about pawn b2 to b3
taking away the very nice looking c4 square from
your knight so the knight gets into c5 yours does
not get into c4 so b5 unfortunately possible f6
that's kind of a tough move psychologically to
play because then you soften up the e6 square and
you like the look of this pawn chain on the light
squares culminating in the d5 h4 and the bonsai
moves okay again f6 is is is the move you're
considering i would go king e7 first probably yep
but now you've allowed a knight which would happen
but is he against training bishops he
might be um well i guess we'll find out
one other thing don is now white to play f5
because d5 is no longer defended so if white
wants to start chiseling at the structure
uh you can go directly for that yeah
and um okay we're okay seven so he's trying to
hold things together yeah i agree with you f5
is an idea e4 there also was almost a mating idea
it sounds weird but right like if the rook was on
c1 yeah it still exists it can play rooks like
one he could play b5 and try to take this thing
wow it doesn't work anymore but it was just
keeping an eye out on this rook take d6 sec it
said nihal is ten seconds look at the time yeah
that's great that is i mean and the position is
that rook takes b6 bishop c7 he wants to play okay
that's the number three bishop e3 you hit you take
back on b6 with a fork yeah that might actually
maybe you take and go rook d7 how bad is that
is the question i'm wondering the same exact thing
he does do it he hasn't oh he is rupee five rookie
five same idea oh wow it's incredible and he'll
find it he's got time the work on a7 is still
hanging back there so rook b5 is a move that saves
rookie please 66 no that's definitely a concession
okay and he goes b5 now he finally exploits that
rook he's still dominating here i would say yeah
you played b4 oh but then a takes b5 so do not
play b4 that actually hangs the pawn yep so what
oh a b right the rook is undefended yeah and then
thankfully rook c1 maybe roof c1 looks really
nice just attacking this bishop you don't want to
trade too many pieces for white because what you
ideally want to do is swing your rook to c8 and
then over to h8 like start winning some of the
king side pawns keeping pressure on both
sides of the board but wait a speed five
he blundered it will nihal say it he dies that's
a big time swing now rook a7 bishop d3 oh but that
knight c6 and you can't even take the pawn that
was a big blunder it really was a rook c8 rook
h8 still a possibility but that black mango d7 to
f8 to not only protect h7 but shut your rook off
from getting back in the game wow wow wow uh-oh
this is incredible now that you only think four
seconds bishop c6 would threaten checkmate bishop
takes before it opens up the square for the king
he's got one second he's got to move he barely
got that off and bishop oh she goes up six oh
king e4 and mate next move with bishop wow take on
possum only yeah bishop seven that was incredible
resistance but i mean too little time yeah bishop
g5 is it's unfortunately for it nihal it's over
and honestly 1-1 feels about right thus
far both players coming up with really
good interesting ideas nihil almost
saved that game and and for sarina
when he has more time he cannot miss moves like a
takes b5 he's far too strong to like overlook that
right i completely agree and um he we know that
he apportions his time very well uh but as you
say he he's got to use it properly in the critical
moments and nihal was very sharp in time pressure
unfortunately uh when you've got five seconds and
there's a lot of pieces on the board your king is
weak it's it's humanly impossible to defend
against all of the threats at the same time
and nihal sauron plays a different line this time
he put knight b5 in the first game now he brings
the bishop back to d2 and starting at castles i
was drawing arrows and knight takes e4 with my
queen g4 clearly there's some sort of theoretical
sequence that i i can't pretend to know but nihal
playing very quickly with the white pieces in
both games this far yeah um both of them seem
relatively comfortable now a6 what's the make of
this position again two bishops for white uh white
has some pressure on the center he can play off
four but obviously he's got that deficiency in
the queen side bond structure black's got a nice
queen on a5 he goes f3 a more measured approach
reinforcing that pawn on e4 yeah f3 is saying
i don't want my queen tied down there and just
in case you had b5 bishop b7 have any ideas of
that not going to allow you to hurt my center
so the e4 pawn and the f3 pawns restrict the
knight and f6 you've talked many times with the
superfluous knights knight on d7 knight on f6 not
quite the case here because nightmare probably
does want to go to c5 or even e5 into c4 so
black's knights are all right for now but i prefer
the potential of the bishops right i agree if you
can stabilize the situation bring the pieces in
another maneuver to keep in mind is the queen
from e2 can do a lot of different things it
can go from f2 to h4 potentially and here we
see niho allowing turnout to take the bishop
uh but that correct white's pawn structure i
would still very seriously consider it though
i think he won the five square this weekend
right i think he threw an e5 as a means of
just gaining space and opening this bishop one
state he could play bishop e6 as well so if
he'd prefer not to trade the knight for the bishop
but keep this knight on c5 it cannot be attacked
by a pawn so it's a pretty good square for it
and keeping the pawn structure ruined for white
then bishop e6 is an idea but then c4 exactly
we're about to say the same thing he takes it oh
yeah i noticed that but somehow i
thought what i didn't realize is that
okay so he goes after the pawn somehow i
thought lex king would experience trouble
what nihal is trying to do is go perhaps bishop
c through rook b1 rook v1 yup and takes b7 what's
is oh but maybe queen a2 rook d8 maybe something
like this this is that i can always plug my knife
yeah plunk it in there yeah this is this is
happening and black has no means of stopping
it thanks to the c4e4 bind he does it yeah i mean
i think this has been a successful happen don't go
queen a3 because of bishop b4 the black choices
are limited i think to queen a4 and 2.82 wait a
minute queen a2 the queen is almost trapped i was
thinking the same thing but there is a b2 queen
there is but maybe something he didn't like about
that or he wants to bring the queen back to c6
potentially or keep it on a4 to pressure c4 rook
fca comes to mind true and this still is knight
d5 you can take queen take c4 so it plays rook to
b8 okay trying to get the rook out of the picture
and you can bring the other rook to defend but
you have to watch out for your back rank you do
it's not like you're going to checkmate it just
you don't want to uh allow black's forces in and
then one important thing here is even if that
pawn on b7 had remained if this knight is traded
off on d5 you get this protected pass pawn there
that's just a big problem for black to deal with
for the rest of the game i love me a protected
pass pawn another thing to deal with uh that
pawn on a6 that is an outside passer so you want
to be careful about treating too many pieces
for whites that's very far in the future but
this is something i've actually learned from you
uh grandmaster hess is forecasting you know
constantly what will happen in an end game
what will happen upon end game what will happen
in the event of a liquidation and that pawn on a6
it may seem insignificant but it could bring black
some sort of advantage of course uh i like nihal's
position here if he can consider knight d5
he can also bring his rook in via d1 okay
well we both like the position dynamically for
white but i'm with you that the long term like
if you just deal with your king the king looks
very safe on shape but with a knight on d5 you
always have to look out for that the bishop on c3
also trying to stare through the pawn on e5 to the
g7 square so if the king gets safe you don't have
to be alert for tactics and forks then this a pawn
down line is certainly a useful pawn it's kind of
weak at the moment but in the future it could be
yeah yeah exactly um and where there's positional
chess uh you have to speak in a russian accent
it makes me sound like i actually know what
i'm talking about which i usually don't
for the record now definitely do you just
you know don't be so hard on what's up
thank you well queen a3 it seems like saranac
knows what he's talking about and what he's
playing about because bishop takes d5 is now a
threat winning the bishop obviously nihal sees
that he's thinking about how to defend against it
rook a1 comes to mind then maybe queen c5 check
that's what concerns me and probably him something
like that followed by what bishop 65 even yeah he
plays it so if you're queen to uh c5 there's no
way to block with the white queen because then
you drop the c4 pawn right so here's the check and
the queen needs to stay protecting this pawn so
this should be 585 how do you rate that i don't
know i mean you could they and go f that e51 is
what uh impedes black from playing knight v6 and
attacking c4 immediately you could take and go f6
and the a6 is i think basically untouchable due
to the back rank uh due to rook be one check but
you give white connected and protected passers
that's never something to do with an easy hearts
although it's this very kind of forcing sequence
here bishop d5 e5 rook c8 like you're getting
after this yeah f4 pawn and interesting h6 i think
that white should respond in kind to defend this
king on h1 you could also move your bishop away
because you would prefer to take on d5 with the
c pawn because you want your base pawn you know
you won't even protect that pawn you want it to be
defended and easier to defend and here after
bishop d5 ed5 you're left with this suspicious
looking c4 pawn in light of rook c8 yeah this
remind i mean it's like both of these players
are fighting a war but h3h6 they got to eat their
sandwiches for lunch you know you gotta eat my blt
here uh all right let's continue fighting yeah
you learned from understood very well you know
there's uh you have to take that bite sandwiches
the war rages on i'm just too nervous uh when you
have the opening ceremony of the us championship
i'm finding am i going to play nakamura in the
first round or kamsky uh and the sandwiches just
don't taste as well when you know you're going to
play you know hikaru with black or something the
next day yeah it's you know you don't get to eat a
stress-free meal that's for sure and uh well rook
b3 was played can we stop talking about food okay
yeah and that's where i was trying i'm gonna
have to get on doordash.com rather than just.
this bishop on c3 is hanging thanks the bishop
takes d5 removing the guard you can play queen of
c2 but then you drop the c4 pawn so you're just
trying to highlight that black is immediately
putting pressure on all these squares so white
has to be alert for that and bishop to b2 well
then you're putting your bishop still on a square
that can be attacked so is bishop he won the move
rook a5 i can see yeah there should be one i like
but rookie rook a5 rook b1 and queen g1 maybe
and i was just gonna run my king away but i
wasn't i'm not my not my king so i can just
run it over there no i like that idea though you
know wait do i actually care about this hey bishop
bishop f2 yeah oh king g3 i was that we were
talking about that position bishop f2 is the
idea now yes but you know it's not my king well
it's on g3 we're having a party though it probably
was quite bad knight v6 now is an idea no actually
i can't find actually a check sometimes the king
paradoxically robert is safest when it's on
a square like g3 that's what i was claiming
i don't think it's the case in that particular
variation but i'm just trying to make a broader
accept my compliments okay i will this time so
queen on d4 hits the rook on a1 if that rook takes
on a6 there is that rook b there's still rook
b1 there is and i guess rook d2 is the queen a1
he's got to go king h2 maybe our favorite
move and he does and thankfully for nihal
he's bishop f2 which hits the queen and
defends these squares on the first rank so
i'm starting to like his position i'm starting
to really think that he's the one pressing the
knight on d7 is dominated by this knight on d5
and if you ever take as we've talked about many
many times now just cd and that's a pass pawn
yeah there's some mutually assured destruction
in regards to these two past spawns they can
both disappear from the board and if they do
uh there might be a draw but their position
can still be full of life i mean if the queens
come off the board and the pawns come off the
board okay i think it's going to be a dead draw
but uh we'll see how this is handled so he takes
on a6 so take on c4 with the queen and then yeah
feels like that but white is like a
little faster maybe a little pull yes
okay some pressure okay but no but it's not
i don't think it's serious pressure i think
uh in surnagan he's got that 30-second
advantage and we talked about this last
match it might not seem significant but it
allows him uh to generate accurate defenses
and when necessary pose a lot of problems that
if fate comes to mind as a possibility here
i know that looks very artificial but you want
to go f6 and like king f7 yeah he goes king ffa
oh so bishop before it does not work because the
bishop well that's actually just mass trade right
it's like we just take and take and you take
my bishop you should g3 maybe but okay this is
all very symbolic pressure he goes for it so you
can't play f6 don't hang your bishop that would be
silly wait why not oh just kidding uh there's
actually it looks like it should be five
oh that would be oh that was hanging bishop if
i was hanging directly because the background
instead we see some trades and e5 is hanging
so rooksy five always able to generate some
you know some pressure but i think this is
all very easily resolvable and do we have
don't don't walk your king onto the dark
square king seven yeah yeah that would be
foolish yeah um so king b7 bishop
before we're gonna say rook training
but here's the thing that e5 font being on a
dark square is what really hurts black because
you plant a bishop on g7 there and you're
never entirely sure that it's a draw true
and f6 has the same problem with b7 check you'd
be forced to play rook c7 i take and bishop of
fate at the end so look at this he's already
crazy he's able to rook c2 i would go rook c2
for full activity no but there's bishop f8
there oh anyway yeah i'm just going to pull
my bishop on my face this is okay serrano's going
to move got him one second oh my gosh he goes for
the end game but wait a minute he might lose two
pounds it's a great call robert you know having
f5 is what he's gonna go for he's gonna go for
a five oh no he gives this one up i don't like
that king h king g three king h working g5 isn't
the king just and then well bishop e8 okay this is
really hard to defend with seconds in your clock
but what is white's plan of improvement i would
watch h47 he should he wants the g4 but do not
take do not take this pawn on g4 yeah yeah yeah
because that allows the passer but first i would
make the improvements exactly oh king of faces
yeah that is incredible how did he do that he's
just he just posed you you said about sorry no
problem has more time right when he has more time
he's the one posing these little problems but
this is what nihal did in this game is he was the
opportunist he said hey you're pawn on g7 you're
pawning h6 dark squares my bishop is too powerful
on h7 this is it wow and you never say never you
spot the smallest uh deficiencies in your
opponent's position that's exactly what modern
chess is and uh that that's that's just flat out
impressive with almost no time on the clock yeah
just one of those positions from black's point of
view in that game where you know you should hold
the draw that you you know for certain but you're
like wait push my face that scares me and then he
plays that move f6 and forcing the rooks off the
board and then he loses one pawn then he doesn't
have enough time to figure out the exact proper
defensive maneuvers so here we have a new game
sorry now with the white pieces i once again
prefer his position but we are still pretty early
on he has the fianchetto bishop the more advanced
position however this bishop on a6 is always
annoying it always is it's pesky it's pressuring
c4 and i was just going to say a book could be
written about the end games only the end games in
the jscc robert i mean we've been treated to some
incredible displays both in terms of defending
and attacking and yeah i mean what to make of
this position well knight takes d5 always has to
be reckoned with that's an idea in such positions
i i mean i it has to be considered even here
but ed bishop d5 95 i don't like i feel like
nihal has stabilized the boat here but it's
never entirely equal uh it might be equal
objectively but what i wanted to say is there's
always some intrigue when it comes to the queen
side things could happen there on the c file
yeah and also because white spawns on b3 which is
somewhat atypical of these sort of exchange slav
type of positions the black queen can actually
start making progress here and the bishop on a6
is well placed earlier on you're like with the
bishop on a6 is that really where it wants to be
but the answer is yes because there's no knight b5
and it's harder for white to make inroads here and
actually this looks completely yeah um symmetrical
but yeah i was trying to build it up i do think
that black can play a little bit here i mean
because of the dark squares i think that what
black has the light squares under control whereas
exactly move like queen before could be a bit
frustrating yeah i was considering queen before
you've always got to watch watch out for knight
takes d5 for example but yeah queen takes d2 that
clearly doesn't work right so question after queen
before is how do you actually improve the position
uh let's say white simply passes the move like
king g2 or something what is blocks do you see
anything for black there that's the essential
question that's what we're trying to do that's
a king g2 like how do i pilot more pressure but i
think that there will be a knight e4 jump because
you take with the knight typically that would be
good for white because your knight oh i stole a
piece you know i get your queen back but the c2
rook is hanging so there will be knight e4 type of
jumps because of all the pressure down the c file
so i actually think that queen 4 is a very direct
threat of knight e4 because the bishop takes pawn
takes in comes this bishop to d3 and well thank
you for all the squares on the board indeed that
was very well explained and i think okay kg2 kg7
the sandwiches the blt's gotta get the reuben okay
let's keep fighting down the c file why can't move
his knight also away from c3 that's not impossible
i think that's the smartest thing to do because
queen before can get you under some trouble some
pressure there so i think moving the knight wins
making essentially this is how a frame had done
and i've heard this from many strong grandmasters
if the game is likely going to be a draw but
you can get uh yourself in some trouble make
the draw and we've seen many famous examples of
that where instead of just you know forcing the
pieces off and accepting your fate you say oh
i can i can try i can try and then oftentimes
you get yourself into more trouble than it's
worth and here trading one pair of rooks
alleviates a lot of the pressure in the
position and i think that ultimately
we will see the players uh keep an even game
yeah and those are some of the most sleepless
nights i've had robert in tournaments uh when i've
over pressed these kinds of positions it's just
it's it's excruciating when when you you
know you can't get out of your own way
there's a voice in your head that says all right
time to make a draw time to wind things down
ah you know i can press for free i can make
all these improvements boom the game turns
you know you lose a position that you would have
never dreamed of losing exactly and i mean the
pawn structure completely symmetrical um there's
no weaknesses anywhere there is one thing what is
this all right knight d1 let's say rook takes
you to queen b5 queen f1 but even that is
okay but the g4 square is also weak sorry to
interrupt you no no you made a very good point
that actually this bishop on c4 now is better than
the counterpart on f3 so i'm starting to buy that
nihal's position is looking slightly better just
easier to play and i don't see any problems with
black's position he is i mean we mentioned his
versatility uh he's very sharp calculationally but
what he's also very mature and obviously
as a person but also as a player he's able
to generate these small chances and slowly kind
of twist the knife turn by turn b5 here then g5
and you start to doubt uh the safety of white's
king and the health of his queen side as well
yeah what i do like for sarina is this
clock mansion we're going to say this
very often and we have throughout the jfcc but
bishop b3 played by nihal rook c7 queensland
queen c3 probably should just be uh hey that's
where the scoresheets get signed right but there's
queen c4 type possibilities where bishops before
i would not i would not trade yeah bishop c4 b5
and here's the thing i know i would cons okay i
would say okay queen takes c3 robert why were you
did why were you saying he should play bishops
before i told you he was going to trade queens
that was the best thing but black can still try
to make a couple of moves he's got that c4 score
maybe he sees something in the position like 98
knight d6 hop that knight around into c4 that
would be the dream i called this i said he would
trade queens he wouldn't go bishop supporters
through to my nickname so what what
can either side do here because
i just don't see anything 98.96 maybe f3 king
death 2 like stuff like that i just doesn't seem
like it gets you anywhere i feel like but what
do you do exactly after 98 knight d6 knight c4
do you just go a4 probably go f4 at some point
would be an idea but you're right he's coming
to d6 into c4 like who cares with the g5 pawn
you know what else he might be thinking about
um i don't either i was trying to desperately okay
an idea there we go yeah 98 felt like the move
there and so okay 96 knights before i'm trying
to think even if you get what you're looking for
can i just push my pawn to a4 how bad is that
i think that is has the potential to be very
bad a pawn on the light square against this light
square bishop so if this pawn gets to a4 and stuck
there then this bishop comes to c2 the knight
gets in the game and that could actually be a big
problem right and oh you called it there no before
about it you saw the bar it went immediately in
black's favor because we talked about it because
the e3 pawn is hanging and who cares about g5
right knight g6 knight c4 oh man you draw the
king out and now knight c4 is gonna be a fork
how do you defend the pawn you go before i guess
but man man man then knight e3 knight c2 robert
potentially well my big question is do you start
with a5 to cement this pawn on a light square
or do you just keep going forward knight c4 and
then e4 as you're saying you give yourself an
isolated pawn not good for the end game i'm not
sure this is a very tough decision because a5
if you win that a pawn it's all but over if you
have an outside passer in this kind of end game
you're going to win so that's a very tempting
but the problem with a5 is after takes takes
the moment you go okay goes knight c4 yeah because
you're in 93 knight c2 hits uh both d yeah but d5
is also hanging so you've got to take on e4 there
in the middle but you could take on e4 and then
go knight c2 exactly unbelievable man nihal's
technique too smooth right now karpovian i mean
this is just he's squeezing out just one little
deficiency in white's position square on c4 and
the the presence of mine i think to trade queens
of course they're not going to defend it better
without a doubt but i think he understood that
there was more to the position than met the eye
very very impressive and he brings his bishop out
take an e4 if the bishops trade on e4 there's nice
e2 at the end still i mean look at these pawns
out here they just have wandered yeah it takes
a knight c2 things are things are burning there on
the queen side now if you're starting out how do
you defend this uh you you pawn strategically but
which one you give them yeah yeah v5 so you after
knight c2 you play id5 also possible by the way
oh that's actually better because this f4 pawn
is more important than d4 pawn in my opinion i
agree so knight d5 if b5 you take on f4 and now
oh and then that comes to c8 you're just you're
trying to make a statement that once this knight
gets to c8 these pawns over here are not so
good yeah but the white black knight comes
to c3 and takes a four so 95 or 92 here 92 i
would go 92 to four yeah of course i see it
and uh then yeah knight c well it goes
knight d5 i don't think it really matters
uh because white's gonna have to go knight anyway
i think yeah and then you go knight c3 takes takes
and it's it's a 50 50 game i would say that black
has excellent winning chances there but it could
also ended up drop well the knight a4 stuck for
well you can go knight c3 knight b6 knight b5
and then there's d5 so that's actually a pretty
critical sequence that if white is able to trade
off this d-pawn for this e-pawn these two come off
then it feels like white's chances get all of this
97 check come on t5 yeah this is that one quickly
played two in 16 seconds now what nikhil can try
to do is go after that b-pod with this game a
problem why could potentially give his knight
up for the b pawn his king will come to h5 this
should be a draw this should be a draw but it's
not easy no not easy at all because if you play
knight b4 there's like king d4 king c5 so okay you
do a count you say wait is my king getting here
eight maybe i was thinking about that so you can
stack on b6 that seems yeah knight cc i'm gonna go
g5 knight a8 king c5 g5 so and then you get your
king to f6 and then you the fastest you don't go
king h5 because that takes longer and that's what
nihal is thinking about that's why he went here
yep knight doing no it doesn't work then you take
king f4 maybe but then it's a dropping h6
and he's got two here move f5 played yeah
drop by agreement king h6 98
and then take on b6 take on b5
i think they should play this out they're not
playing in a very combat i don't know what i
signed up what am i commentating with tournament
we're taking quick draws i mean come on this
is ridiculous well you know diana this is why
you signed up for can you guess how old alexi
saranac is in this image oh let's see oh
i'm sorry i'm overcome i would say eight
okay and i don't actually know just oh no no no
no no no no i see what the producer wants to show
my mom really likes this photo how old do
we think you are don't tell us i have no
idea you must i actually need to remember
i have a ballpark estimate i don't know
this is this this is in my room
at home actually were you nine
i think i was nine yeah wow what a guess let's
go amazing oh that's so cute it's gonna make me
blush yeah this is a good photo i remember these
camps that gary kasparov would uh would host for
for talented uh well quote unquote talented young
players that i had the privilege of attending
that was oh come on come on this is too much i
love it people saying dania coaching gary right
oh man no i had that face of man 10
years from now i'll be commentating
15 years from now i'll be
commentating with robert hess
and you're like wow my life is gonna be terrible i
know that's exactly what i was thinking gary saved
me from this man oh well look at this uh position
dinah there's a queen on c7 a rook on c1 usually
the rook wins the stair down with a queen an
open line i'm looking at knight d5 type ideas
where if you take i take and there's a pin on the
knight c6 so bishop g5 step one let's challenge
this knight on f6 and if you are sarnan how
are you dealing with that immediate threat
uh well the question is do you deal with
it by reacting because bishop takes f6
gf yeah knight t5 i mean he goes a6 so he forces
it from the other side now nihal has a decision
bishop f6 robert even here is possible because if
you take the other bishop then of course white has
queen g4 nasty little move oops um in fact winning
on the spot g5 point h6 lobster pins are made
and there's no stopping it yeah well a
f6gf now what i was mentioning is that
once black's king shifts to
h8 and his rook comes to g8
i know the pawn structure looks really bad but
these positions can turn really really quickly
i agree uh but donna one thing i'm looking at is
i hear bishop d3 but was there an opportunity with
like a tactical sequence with knight
d5 ideas anyway so if you took on c6
took on f6 was there a knight d5 here because pawn
takes politics i have queen g4 bishop on d7 i take
on i take on c6 with the pawn oh you took on c6
it's the pawn but then your pawn structure looks
terrible here right like a6 is hanging yeah but am
i not up a piece there what are you talking about
oh i thought okay we were talking about different
things so now i'm looking at your screen i thought
you were still talking about knight t5 no no i
was immediately i got you right i was thinking
of a completely different line got it so bishop
c6 bishop totally innocent now oh that makes
perfect sense of course yeah no that's actually
looked like a really interesting idea yeah now
that we're on the same wavelength if robert has
had proposed that i would have advocated for it
yeah i'm just trying to point out that there
is a pin on the bishop when c6 and queen g4
check will hit the other bishop so it looks
like you're regaining your sacrifice material
and with interest because there's these weak
pawns on the uh f file so we didn't see any
of that he retreated bishop to d3 which is
still probably a good thing nihal taking the
kind of the non-tactical approach but which is
fine because he wants to play f4 e5 and if sir
and i ever play z5 himself there there isn't this
equivalency between the d45 squares white has
easier access to it than black because black's you
know the bishop the bishop's counterpart is on d7
and not on e6 right that's a very good point that
you know it's annoying for black because after
especially after f4 you want to play e5 to stop
that pawn from e4 from pushing itself but that
gives up it vacates the defense of the d5 screen
look at white's pieces the third rank attack
these knights and bishops all are just doing
very well here you could slide the bishop to b1
prophylactically just getting it out of the danger
zone that's not truly necessary yet you could also
okay five he goes for the direct approach he opens
up the bishop there are already some sacrifices
i'd be thinking about once the rook gets to f3 on
h7 right so you could swing you right to age of a
check with the queen h5 and you can also start
with bishop e4 here keep that bishop does so
safe and sound queen h5 be careful don't do that
because of f5 good point so let's show queens of
f5 hits the queen hits the bishop no ambassador
for you exactly now is there a knight before for
you probably not because of knight takes d4 and
queen takes c1 yes that would so that rook on b5
that's an interesting idea by sarna right he's
trying to change the course of the game he's
trying to get me hulk to think uh and i would
still consider going rook f3 here just continuing
with my king side strap she goes king h1 stepping
away for the time being he wants to go knight d4
your idea spoke volumes to him because now knight
d4 even though you're queen on e2 under attack
it's not under attack with check so knight
takes rook c7 92 before would have checked
your king on g1 now you take the queen i
take the rook and thank you for at least
an extra exchange and probably more coming out
indeed at 94 rook c5 there's knight takes e6
so i mean where does black even go at rook
before rook a5 but that is not a movie you play
you know if you're in love with your position no
certainly not so knight d4 just challenges black
immediately to come up with a couple moves that
save the day but the first move is probably
the easier one like rook a5 for example is after
that like how do you continue to fend off what is
mounting pressure i would play a3 you could sort
of yep he plays slowly and uh there's nothing
wrong with that it's very hard for black
to even make a move here i agree i would i
would start thinking about sacrifices along
the lines of f5 right not also that rook on
uh and f5 we're just trying to break open the
position but we do acknowledge the e5 pawn is
hanging we're talking kind of just as ideas even
if the ideas don't work in the immediate position
it's good to have them store them figure
out later yep yeah i know i think queen d1
but then we can come back to a5 and i cannot quite
fly into the crushing can you just take on c6 down
here and just like get a better pawn structure
you absolutely can and perhaps you should like
knight c bishop c6 takes pawn takes and you're
right your pawn is here so you have a weak
queen side but something tells me that's not the
most that i can squeeze out of the position what
neil has to be very careful about is not to
obviously not to take too much time here goes
queen c2 okay now rook a5 what is this idea is
rook i5 even forced i think it is and then you go
quite see it i want to go to knight b3 but then
your work goes to like b5 somehow serena holds
this together you could go queen b3 and
again you can take on c6 as you proposed
uh at the right moment queen b3 will threaten
bishop b6 after that by the way true so you know
rookie rook a5 queen b3 trying to get the bishop
to the b6 square and there's 96 sacrifices that
at some point yeah and again he's got the threat
of knight c6 or even potentially e6 and bishop b6
all right how do you say square on v6
how do you see rook a4 is one idea yeah
you might have to play rook a4 but bishop c bishop
c2 rook c4 okay wow barely escaping barely but
he does it and you could double on the sea
follow if you're knee hall you could add some
spice with rook c3 potentially but then the queen
drops away from the c file you start feeling
yeah one gets the sense that's not the most that
i could do right but you want to be practical
in regards to your clock also yeah i'm like really
trying to find that knockout bishop f3 so he can
move his knight without dropping his bishop on
e4 and the only place he could have moved was to
c6 which would have been fine but now he can
move his knight elsewhere and continue to go
after this rook on a4 right but i like the move
queen b8 finally solving the problem of the pin
uh the knight on c6 can now move it might be
time for nihal to say all right i'm going to
take on c6 i'm going to relinquish uh the the
rook from my clutches but no he goes knight v3
now there is a positional component
to this idea if he goes knight c5
uh he he may potentially force the trade and
those dark squares around black's game ooh
yeah not good bishop a7 bishop was
the first one that came to my mind
you just go queen a8 and it's uh not that yeah
exactly knight c5 maybe should be preferred
nice i don't know about what knee haul is doing
i mean maybe it'll backfire but i guess we'll see
in the next couple of moves yeah this is well
the f4 pawn is also a little tender actually
so if you play knight c5 maybe he'll just take
you on c5 and win your f4 pawn so the rook on
yeah that was on b5 and a5 and a4 it's doing
a good job so i would play knight d2 perhaps
because this configuration with rook a4 knight to
a5 it's sort of offside looks kind of questionable
so keeping the pieces on the board
he plays it but after taking on c8
honestly i'm trying to figure out the
same thing because he gives black a c file
c2 bishop d1 i mean it's that's what he
wanted to play bishop d1 and with his rook
on c1 he couldn't do that oh that makes
sense because it would have been hanging
yeah so he could play bishop d1 the rook goes
to a5 knight to c4 for example looks really
nice e4 also wait that wins the exchange yeah
rook five minutes oh my goodness wait but rook
b5 bishop bishop b4 and then rook d5 there's
knight b6 amazing he got to the rook at last
it took a while but he did but he got to it
eventually and that b6 square it's killed
black first the bishop threatened to appear there
and now the knight threatens to appear there and
serenade loses the exchange he's got to give it
up in the most strategic way maybe drop his knight
back to d8 for example try to take on b5 with the
bishop but at that point there's knight b6 with
tempo if knee hall even wants to unpin his knight
which he doesn't have to you play b3 exactly
or we're c1 and b3 some kind of yeah exactly
combination of moves this is losing whoa whoa
what's happening if this one if i take it and [ __
] knight b6 and knight b and mb6 looks good i mean
quincy two no quizzy two i just take b yeah no
there's nothing i'm just trying to figure out i
mean queen d you have to give up the piece i think
and go go after okay queen c6 rook c1 even there
was possible i i think it was smart by sarna all
things knight p3 his position was losing right
it's been lost but this way at least you know in
seven seconds for white you need to figure things
out so bishop takes b4 which is a great move
actually yes making everything safe now knight
c896 is a maneuver that comes to mind you've got
to do something with your knife you've also got to
do something he's got three seconds oh a nice move
pinning the knight just you crazy we're trying
okay queen is you could put a three at some point
five ninety six okay he's gotta push his pawns but
he's gotta watch his king also discern uh that's
easier said than done he's got no pieces to do
it with and this should just be absolutely
frustrating yeah yeah yeah queen b7 uh he's
gotta be home yeah he barely got that move off
seconds he's got oh my gosh he really on my lap
he's got a premium there we go he just played
any move yeah and so to start up bishop d4
and you can trade queens go g4 f5 yes you can
why yeah five wins and takes f6
before f7 he promotes in time
yeah what a game wow he almost lost some time
though he made him that was pointless six
seconds yeah i was i mean when you see that clock
dipping below a second i that's where i start just
getting really nervous and that worries me for
sure but if you're a nihal sauron fan you're like
well i mean he is a another bullet yeah just
knows what he's doing casual bullet scramble
and nihal getting out to the fast
start in the longer time patrols that
does spell big trouble for alexis sarnath
because sarnath won his match against jeffrey
in the longer time patrols what's up sorry i
was this is theory but if you go back to move
11 i thought knight h4 won the queen but then i
remembered it is a line because of knight takes d4
right so you sorry i just i not every day you
see the queen getting five of ten that's why i
excited no it's good good to keep an eye on
that because you can mix up your lines and
then that would actually trap the queen so
instead we see black castle fully developed
the bishop on c8 not exactly the best piece
in the world but white has these issues on
the king side you played g4 but you're not
getting an attack and so maybe that created
more weak squares than it was right something like
e5 comes to mind now in reference to your point
about the five minute segment going knee hall's
way uh you know i think saranas playing decently
i don't think he's showing necessarily bad
form um but with that being said what negal
is doing so well is exploiting small advantages
we saw this game after game first at c5 square
then that rook which was misplaced but he thought
to persistently try to trap it and eventually he
succeeded and this ability to capitalize on
small advantages is um well it's the hallmark
of an incredibly talented player and uh sir now is
going to have to tighten up his play a little bit
if he is to right the ship here yeah he does
and you know this position the two bishops
there's potential here that's what
we're going to talk about that white has
long-term potential and black if you just
sit and do nothing then the advantage for
white will increase because moves like rook c1
eventually trying to play e4 that's all going to
be nice for white the knight and c6 is kind of
stuck where it is it would love to go a5 to b3
for example but then the e5 square is given up and
you do not want to see that white nightland there
with the bishop on g2 opening up so i do believe
that white holds the advantages in this position
and i'm not quite certain maybe you can tell me
what should black's strategy be in the next bunch
of moves i would go for for some sort of sacrifice
e5 d e knight f4 i would do it here i would do it
in like four seconds i'd play e5 and again because
i love sacrificing other people's pieces i know
nihal style can be sometimes more measured than
that but i would i would not be able to resist
i'm going to tell you that right now i would
go e5 here so i'm just going to point out that
dania is trying to take advantage of the rook
staring down the queen so in the event of e5 if
you take with the pawn or the knight let's say
we trade knights and you go knight f4 this is a
little bit different and that's why i took with
the knight on e5 so i gave my bishop a square
but don just pointing out that the bishop on d2
is pinned to the queen on d1 and thus black has
a ton of counter play for the second right and i'm
not pretending like black isn't worse he's worse
but you have to identify the moments the other
idea that i thought was rook a6 rook b6 but that
seems a little bit more artificial to me you have
to identify a moment when okay you tell yourself
i'm going to change the course of the game i'm
going to make my opponent sweat a little bit
but with this time disparity if he hull sort of
just hunkers down i don't see this going well
for him at all but if he plays e5 with the time
difference that we see right now i mean it just
feels like that also yeah and i do want to point
out once more that taking with the knight on e5
for what is important because after e5 d e knight
f4 now my bishop on g2 doesn't have anywhere to go
so that's a huge problem that the bishop on d2
is pinned otherwise it was the queen and the
bishop g would have to go back to f1 if you're
going to keep it that's why i'm taking with the
knight on e5 if e5 is indeed played right that's
that's a great point and with every passing second
things are getting more concerning for niall
he's two and a half minutes down the clock and
you you said it robert okay he goes bishop d7
he was definitely considering e5 for i would
say the entirety of this time yes but now that
he's played bishop b7 it's so clear that white
yeah that's an admission that things have gone
very wrong in the opening he's probably going
to put his bishop on ea we we know how good
nihal is holding these positions together
he's going to be very hard to bring down but with
this time disparity we also know that sarnath
is a monster in terms of posing problems uh in
opponent's time pressure in this kind of position
he's good at holding these positions from
black side of things i am not so that's why
as a commentator i'm kind of like looking at
this and if i this were a classical game of
chess i'd be sitting there my head in my hands
completely miserable i can't do anything and
i have to be worried is e4 coming right now or
wait not yet it's just e3 then after e3 it can
just build it up and how can i actually create
some active play for myself your rook a6 rook
b6 idea that certainly comes to mind and i think
that's what nihal will need to do if he is going
to avoid being just grabbing yeah f6 bishop
g6 another one of these maneuvers to slightly
enliven his position he goes f6 i would even
think about the exchange stack on c6 absolutely
uh and and that seems like a very interesting idea
but at least that unbalances the position black's
goal here is to breathe some doubt into white's uh
into sorana's mind about his capacity to win this
game e5 by the way still exists maybe not here
i mean that creates so many weaknesses 97 okay
yeah actually i do like that this bishop on e4
though that went from c8 to d7 to e8 to g6 to e4
got him in a diamond shape yeah
rhomboid a very french-like idea
and hey c6 okay so what does he accomplish he
traded the bishops definitely in black's favor
sarnath getting his knight i think to d3
okay and then what well you tell me robert
i'm trying to figure that out because i still
like white's position i just don't know how to
make process because e4 yeah we did now the knight
can come to b5 those knights in this kind of close
position robert are very jumpy you know they can
all of a sudden put tremendous pressure on a pawn
i like the way things are going here for nihal
and the f4 square is under control thanks to
oh miss wait a minute nice you could second
exchange here and go nah that doesn't work
because the rook penetrates the a7 so i
would go rook d7 but then maybe takes in d5
that's not good yeah the 997 actually is well
positioned to meet d5 as they protect c6 so you
don't have to shatter your own pawnshop shirt
this pawn a4 though dania that's one that may
have extended a little bit too far but so is
this pawn on d4 now that the e pawn has pushed
there's two ideas one is g5 knight g6 knight f4
and the other is knight c8 knight t6 and i this
idea of putting as soon as the knight appears on
f4 boy oh boy is there going to be trouble for
white potentially i would go g5 here i would also
play g5 because do you yeah you do need g5 because
you play knight g6 right away king g3 and then
wait yeah i want to get to f4 but i can't you want
to secure that square for yourself now why can
g5 white can protect that square with his knight
but that would mean uh making the knight more
passive let's say on g2 yeah not good not not what
you want so what is knee hall thinking about here
well there's other moves you can double on the d
file but i would go for active defense okay
he does double on the d file yeah the a4 pawn
is hanging immediately so you can take
that but you'll lose d4 so what was yours
oh that's a problem for sure knight c2 maybe
should be preferred but then you go yeah exactly
that's exactly the kind of sound i would e5 even
stack that up on an a4 and get that e5 here and
get that knight c4 e5 yeah e5 looks very good
and actually after d e you can throw in b5 if
you really want right okay this is where 45 but i
guess you can go right now no dinah this is where
the time is very important because nihal doesn't
enough time to start calculating things like
pushing the pawn to b5 what are the consequences
i'm not sure why he didn't target that at four
square honestly it seems like he doesn't have it
in his sights and i feel like this by and large
let's alexi off the hook here but still even he
puts his knight on b5 this makes perfect sense as
well of course yeah but the rook on eight tied to
the defense of the a4 pawn so it's a frustrating
position of your knee haul when you have 20
seconds left you're like do i play c5 do i play e5
you can't play c5 19 can i play e5 no i don't want
that exactly he's just he's not quite coming up
with a clear plan b5 knight c4 is not going to
happen because his knight can always go to e3 so
you want to look where the outposts are and then
for from serrano's point of view you're trying to
stop that like you said the f4 square the c4 score
on the other side of the board is one you want to
keep that knight out back as well and here comes
knight e3 improving the position and knight be
fighting with d5 so don't yep do that d5 still
possible he's starting to take the air out of
box coordination here d5 maybe e yeah f4
as well just like just push these things
yep and then king can slide over to f3 and protect
e4 if necessary the all keeps shifting the knight
you could go rook c4 rook c4 then rook d8 because
if you take on a4 that's a good call h4 so he does
something similar to what he said driving the pawn
to h5 but here comes the whole attacking the fun
okay so knight c2 um and then maybe nah that's
too much i would still go e5 there i mean
that idea still exists knight c2 e5
and try to get that knight over to f4
i completely agree but i think he's he's
not quite certain that it will work in his
favor and with no time he can't figure out
his labor gate oh we played b5 okay good e3
that was a good move build e5 i mean this idea has
existed for all you he goes g5 now h5 is possible
covering that square but it likes he takes it he
wants the tempo and he wants the h file and he
gets it then i can't move without dropping c6 rook
a7 maybe get the rook around he defends c6 instead
so there's some e5 could be a timely shot to kick
the rook away from the defensive c6 one the knight
is covering for now but if the knight moves away
then e5 could be an idea but i just don't see
the exact sequence that takes advantage so knight
b4 is also an idea just to go right after c6
and give up d4 but that should be uh liquidation
right and he's sort of waiting for that to happen
so we're not poking and prodding six seconds to
the clock with two a minute uh alexi okay he goes
knight v4 there we go now what are we going to
see here white is definitely the one playing here
for a win especially with two seconds what does
black dude does he do a pair of rooks e5 oh rookie
rookie take e6 yeah and then take b5 and f6 is
going to be weak this does not look good but you
also have this idea of doubling on the second rank
that's going to be a mate threat it will be five
e5 e5 always yeah just take on it but e5 there's
still might be rook to d2 yeah might be winning
there watch out you need to be very careful
let's meet this one b6 is winning and serena
well is this easily winning though because somehow
white's king is boxed in it's no this is wrong
i've seen this position before and like there you
go rookie three yes this is a draw it's like a van
well game or something this is amazing you're
like i mean i've seen something similar before
but this is still amazing to me there isn't even
an attempt here no you're a rook f5 kg6 you just
have no moves the only moves that white has king
h3 king g3 you're not getting out of this well
he's got to give up e5 it seems and you know make
a couple moves there but that's a dead draw with
the pawns arranged the way that the way that they
are other than f4 there's no attacks yeah because
rook f6 qg7 you can't push your e pawn because it
needs to say defending this rook on f6 so this is
been seen before and it's a draw wow that is
crazy to think of this with almost no time on the
clock f4 rookie three that's the key detail and i
think serena is coming to terms with it right now
yeah this is this is okay king f7 you have to
make sure you don't drop your g5 pawn that would
be tragic exactly whites yeah this is white's
really only attempt in black's time pressure
try to get the king t i've seen this position
be lost before uh when the king gets to e4 and
somehow makes its way to f5 right but i think
the hull knows what he's doing here yeah the
problem is if the king leaves the f3 pawn falls
and that's why you see a rook f4 oh right four
would have iced it right but this take on f3 now
we have yeah and rook f7 the jeep on there is just
no attempts normally if there's a non-jeep on and
you get you know okay but now even the six ranked
defense yeah exactly so if g6 is played then
you bring your rook to a once you yeah with with
the pawn on the g5 you can even keep your rook on
the eighth rank which is something is a big no-no
normally in the end game yes but i think it's
important for everyone to know that you often want
to put your rook behind but you want to wait kind
of counterintuitively you want to wait until the
pawn gets the sixth rank i'll show that uh when
this game concludes just because i think it's a
very important endgame lesson for people to see so
let me show that uh i bring up the analysis board
and at the end here before g6 is played like let's
say you play rook to b1 then white has his king h6
movement you're right don you always have the
eighth ranked defense but i think just people
like to give a check from behind but then the king
enters this position with a checkmating threat and
so i force your king out from the opposition and
then i will be able to push my pawn and win so
king f8 check you here kg7 i push my pawn i build
the bridge and i win the game right uh if you
check back from here then there's g6 you need to
know that you have this eighth ranked defense it
comes in kind of obviously at this point because
if you stop checkmate but you just want to wait
until the pawn pushes and then get the rook behind
that's uh the essential lessons let's go to the
live board because they're blitzing things out
here they both have about five minutes with 17.
so they're deep in theoretical waters right and we
saw in in alexis previous match jeffrey struggled
for this a little bit he would get some promising
positions and he would falter in in critical
moments when when he had a chance for an advantage
and now we see alexia i think in some regards
uh and in large part due to nihal's resilience and
his ability to generate uh incredible defensive
chances that previous game really hurts robert yes
it did because yeah just were points where it felt
like sauron was making progress and he was right
he got to a position where he was up two pawns
in a rook end game and yet couldn't win based on
the uh position that's something that's extremely
frustrating but i don't think sarna does he really
get that tilted no i think he's well he's anybody
who makes it this far in the jscc possesses a
incredible set of qualities period and one of
them i think is inevitably the ability to stay
level-headed in times of of trouble and uh it
would be an interesting statistic to see how many
times both of these players have been trailing
in their jscc matches maybe something that
will look up over the break but both of them
are incredibly level-headed and very hard to
sort of psychologically unsettle well diane they
have been trailing it certainly wasn't in their
semi-final match-ups because they both won yeah
one-sided affairs even though the end score
for sauron versus jeffrey was like three
maybe but it's because jeffrey started winning
a bunch of bullet games and before that
uh alexis was out and leading speaking of
out in the lead this pawn on d6 that's a
passer that you're going to struggle to fend off
because the bishop on b3 is an attacking piece
the pawn on d6 is a nice weapon and you just pass
bomb that's hard to gain yeah it is a pass pawn
and uh this is a very interesting type of position
where black's also got to watch out for the safety
of this king because in the effort to stop the
past one i've seen many games where black neglects
uh to keep his king safe and
there's some sort of back rank idea
now i think objectively this game should probably
end in a well i don't know queen b7 rook d7
i'm trying to think in that position and queen
of fate is possible oh that's nasty no this is
nasty oh and i can also say bishop a4 i've
already protected my d6 pawns right and just
push oh yeah you can because the queen from v8
is protecting it that's just game over actually
and he does wait so after queen after queen b7
what do you even do look at fate ah come on man
that was the first move i said and i have to admit
like when i said queen f8 that was my idea of
going for f7 and protecting d6 but then i
looked at the uh evaluation bar off the side
and queen f8 doesn't look here let's go back
one move plus 3.74 okay queen of fate is a
move that looks good it's not plus 3.74 right
94 is a great defensive resource by saranac
targeting white's king queen takes f2 is a
big threat whoa whoa actually overlook yeah
and now this thing's turning around completely
don't they yeah having that bar though man that's
just imagine if the players at a bar you said plus
3.7 you immediately find bishop right exactly it's
one of those things you know you hear it you're
like okay there's a there's a crushing blow
uh and then your brain primes you
and guides you into finding it
unbelievable the move 94 i think what's hard to
see is how suddenly black poses threats against
white's king you know you're dominating you're
threatening black skin all of a sudden queen
takes f2 huge threat gotta attend to that play
rook f1 sad necessity i think yeah rook foreign
do you have something like queen e8 oh
i like that king h1 i don't have no idea
wait but that's really fascinating because the
rook on e8 needs a defender right so dania's ideas
of queen f2 king h1 like you can give a check but
then when i go k2 you still have this well there's
perpetual queen f4 i think you can give the
rook and go 92 but you're not going to get more
for more than perpetual out of that discovery he
does it wow queen aid's a huge move to find there
because knight takes f2 what's happening there
like there's a discovery rook d5 maybe oh that's a
the knight you take the hits and
you say i'm gonna go after that
so don is saying rook to d5 hitting the queen
knight h3 is a double check it's not often you
allow a double check and still uh are the side
that's happy but queen g1 just one check thank
you for your night and well good night right let's
see what you did there but if you make one more of
those funds i might exit the tournament yeah so
queen f2 your laugh covered up my fun actually
i said if you make one of those one more of those
ones i might have to exit the tournament he hall
rather than commentating i made this come i
made this one last time so i won't do it now
uh anyways let's get back to the game um and so
why is this so okay for white because you've lost
a pawn your king on h1 doesn't feel the same
sound is it just the claim that this d6 pawn
is full compensation because i see the bars
as zeros and i look at the position i'm like
i don't really see why this is full of quality
it's the kind of zeros though that could turn
either way white could either easily lose
that pawn or black could allow it to move
to d7 i could see this turning either
way i feel like it's dynamic equality
by black maybe and there might be a take take
bishop a4 again that you have to watch out for
because then i can push my pawn to d7 so queen
c5 if i trade but bishop a4 rook d7 like if you
ever capture on d7 you're walking into a pin so
i'll have a move like rook c1 to go after your
pawns so the black king can end up running into
e7 the white rook will probably take some pawns
and maybe that's just what is needed for white
to survive and here's a6 sort of a level-headed
move just making some small improvements and
preparing b5 against bishop a4 that's true
although i'm sorry i like this d6 pawn again for
a moment i was worried about white's king but
white king's not really in true games safe now but
what exactly does white do here i mean it's the
kind of position rook c1 bishop c2 seems a little
bit artificial that came to my mind though okay
actually that actually doesn't look that bad for
me because it also threatens some rook c7 concepts
the one thing that concerns me well there's
a couple of things one is the b3 bishop is
undefended now might seem insignificant
but that's something to keep an eye on
oh between c5 maybe you take and go a5 and
fix that pawn on a light square i like that
for sure the pawn a6 is not very happy
to be there but there's knight e8 or
bishop c4 i don't know yeah rook takes d6 you
take twice c4 and then knight my man after
knight e43 knight f2 check so you have to
be very careful oh come on you faked me out
you thought i was going for the d6 pawn but no
no i was thinking i played bishop c4 please do
that i'm not going to because i was seeing that
knight on e8 i thought yeah i thought you win 98.
oh okay goddess 98 bishop c4 you're not allowed
to play 94 that's two that's too aggressive
sorry sorry my friend even though
this probably still is going to be a
good position for black likes kind of c4
indeed and so we're not taking his time now
as he should he can go a5 and fix the buns that
would not be a good move yielding the b5 square
then bishop c4 yeah a5 bishop c4 get that bishop
to b5 that's kind of an outpost for that piece
too good to be true yeah so it's a big decision
here to be made it's a very sort of amorphous
position robert it's hard to make heads or tails
of exactly what you do here and this queen enough
to sort of need to stay here because queen f5
check will also be annoying right like if your
queen is gone i get this check you can't play
g6 because your knight would be under attack
right so just feels tougher for black to play
even if black is better let's say that's the
objective evaluation i just don't see an easy
move yeah it's it's it's not zoom spine but
i say that you know with a smile on my face
but okay queen h2o that is a very bold move
we'd have five check and be met with g6 but
something about this move seems a little bit
concerning but nihal has only 27 seconds
to figure out what that is maybe bishop
c2 check bishop c2 there's still g6 and the
king the king doesn't want to go to g7 that's
where does the queen go g5 yeah it has to but
then wait a second we see a bishop c2 track
yeah i don't really want to trade queens that
queen f2 your idea then rook have four maybe
now bishops do g6 i guess he takes okay so this is
f7 is possible and so is bishop so yep but bishop
a6 i feel like black is squarely playing for a
win in green he goes for this and there's no ns
there's no mate along this floor because of the
font on g5 yep takes d6 is black pressing here
probably slightly better has to be right but the
point is rook d6 you can't take on e8 because your
rook's under attack so that uh rook g4 a nice
move to win a pawn at least in the knight six
though crowd attacking the bishop now bishop b3
oh bishop b3 you can't you cannot cannot attack
the bishop because of bishop c2 good point look
at this you've got to play rook d2 and rook g5
and you've restored material quality i would press
of course if you're black because before seconds
when there is a night there's trouble as we know
and rookie five there's knight c5 trying to go 93
and then a four type of ideas bishop c4 links the
bishop to the a6 spot now the pawn might be lost
he's gonna move he's gonna move rookie six check
he's trying to take on b6 played down a piece
i don't know that's a very interesting idea i
think it's lost it has to be yeah especially with
no time on the clock he goes a5 instead which oh
please take me on a5 because of rookie six check
oh just a little tricky a little tricky yeah
he knew he was gonna lose that pawn anyway
and this has to be a win for black right it does
but i actually once drew a similar position over
the board against bouchon g chinese grandmaster
and i had a i had a bishop but it was one of those
like two pawns against one situation you think
he has to be winning but with a knight the knight
can chisel its way into white's position here
with well maybe you can even take here i think
yeah there could be a rook swap and then you
bring the king in but he's doing it this way
there could be a meeting next to me sure like
could there be like some kind of king h4 knight g3
type of mating out as well too much to ask for
yeah also you're gonna have to watch for stalemate
ideas if you put a king king on h4 knight on
g3 that is in effect stalemates white's pawns
true okay so he's using his knight as a cover
the one thing you have to watch out for if you're
black isn't obviously not to lose that
g-pawn oh we train no what happens here
this is gotta be losing king f5 so king of
five kh for this king f4 yeah yeah and then g4
g5 and 94. you really want white to push the
pawns because g5 you would or would not i would
okay sorry i interrupted you no no i'm just
gonna say that you okay this is what you want
for uh sorry not as soon as you push the pawns
they become weaker the pawn g2 is very hard to
get to the pawn on g4 is extremely easy to
get so look the king's already boxed out
g5 and g5 it's it's over i mean that knight easily
limits the pawn and it zooms along and it's over
and that's a that's a big game big game for alexi
with the black pieces as they enter the last game
of the five minute segment wow we've already
been here for almost an hour and a half that's
crazy i feel like it's game one these games have
been so saturated so full of life and complexity
i actually really cannot believe that like i know
the score is four to three i see that in front
of me but i feel like we're still in like the
third game yeah i know i feel like i was gonna
say exactly the same thing i i feel enthused and
energetic and so we have this position we've seen
it before these are the questions that we tend to
ask each other who will blink first who's going
to change their opening and the quicker time
patrols but yeah sarna likes this position he
hasn't played g4 yet so that's a big difference
between this game and some of the others and
because i guess he hadn't played g4 incomes
e5 as the queen defends the e5 square right
and he's opening up the center and i like that
he's doing it much faster this game we saw him
get in trouble once the position gets cramped uh
you know the opportunity doesn't come around again
and uh serrano taking the first thing which is
always a good sign for for his opponents because
he's really known as as an opening
specialist we've discussed that
yeah the bar just went crazy three that's what
i was looking at he that oh this knight is in
trouble too nasty no this is there this
is wait knight takes c3 queen a5 and g5
oh my gosh tonight traps is that your claim
all my lands so it's a queen a queen of six c3
i'm going to show that real quick knight c3 if you
take on f5 i take on d1 i'm up a piece because my
bishop attacks your knight so bc queen a5 and g5
next move traps the knight was over excited about
this or did not actually win the game no you're
you're totally right then i strapped out there
yep and what he's done is also very advantageous
take steps too but at least his gifts are not
some light but i i assure you donya that alexia
will not be repeating this exact variation why
would you think so robert don't make him jump
to conclusions i mean this is a very good line
i love how you're trying to say that with a
straight face this is something that you you have
that one time mistake and you absolutely never do
it again right okay dad cross that off the list
exactly and i i just want to see it looked
interesting i mean the e3 square there's a knight
that is replacing them this is still so nasty and
it's easy for me to criticize and say i should
have seen this and this but my coach would always
talk about this which he would call the narrowing
bridge where when you're winning it's like when
you enter the bridge it's very very wide and
then the further along you go it becomes narrower
and narrower so you want to be very careful about
being a little bit too cavalier in terms of uh
pressing on the gas pedal here you want to win
the game uh swiftly and you want to pounce while
the iron is still hot if that makes sense i'm with
you because if you do let this king castle by hand
or then all of a sudden you're like wait where'd
my advantage go also you also pollute your own
mind by thinking i was much better if not winning
i should still be that where that may not be
the case rookie 3 is certainly a good move
you are just shutting down white's
plans you just bring the next rook in
yeah so now it's trying to castle by hand
rook f1 king g1 problem with rook f1 is
that it well queen g6 here is possible as a
prophylactic move against king g1 and then g4
weakens the force there's also queen h6 hitting
h3 threatening knight c3 rook f5 oh no something
like that yeah very that's i think that's a
brilliant move actually it's like queen h6 h4
i'm just chose knight c3 politics rook f3 check
and now there would be a background checkmate
but after ef3 queen d2 is checked to your
miserable king and this is definitely a critical
moment where nihal is i think deciding between
these two moves also queen d6 is possible again
uh coming at it from the other angle but i really
like the movement h6 i think it just doesn't
end the game immediately it very well might
it could but it just i don't know questions
i feel like your moves though are more
natural queen g6 in particular just feels
so simplistic yeah in a good way right exactly
and no you want to be some sort of simple and
straightforward and people think that's that's
bad and every idea has to be super complex it
doesn't you know if you play simply sometimes that
means your idea is healthier yeah i like queen g6
actually because the knight can't move from f3 the
g3 pawn is hanging thinks the rook on e3 it feels
like white can't really even move so queen g6 is
just one step of many in the right direction yeah
the one thing is well you want to play quickly
right two minutes two minutes on the clock and
i get a two minute advantage now for alexi i know
that might be insignificant in a winning position
but i'm looking at queen d695 you know there's
a lot of the stuff that you're going to have
to process and you need time to do that robert yes
so for still always crazy amount of time for alexi
but not a great position and uh i'm just looking
here for a second once so you know we see that
what's neon thinking about exactly because
he plays take on c3 first and queen e7
now that is something we didn't factor in a very
positional approach he's going after that a pawn
and simultaneously keeping an eye on the e2 pawn
we've seen two knight a5 knight c4 i mean it we've
seen his ideas uh can can look a little bit you
know they can look like they don't carry a punch
but they almost always do uh so i'm trying to give
them the benefit of the doubt here but queen b2
95 not a5 knight e5 i don't know yeah i think
what we're trying to highlight is that he could
have taken that bishop once c through at any
point so taking it immediately unless you have
a very concrete plan in which case he does to
take on a3 next it almost wouldn't be worth it
but queen b2 dino's point the knight come to
a5 trying to get to the c4 square but then you
free up the e5 square for white's knight and
that's when things get complicated and that's
when things start to turn around especially when
white is well ahead in the clock the funny thing
is if you could capture your own pieces after
queen b2 queen takes e3 would be checkmate
that's actually really funny queen takes rook mate
so knight h4 played queen g5 there's knight takes
f5 what about bishop takes h3 and then queen
g5 and [ __ ] that's too much i mean i actually
i like that was that two point knight f5 brook
afternoon queen g5 there we had knighthood there
was rook up three anyway so actually and these
kind of moves just might have been good knight
f5 rook f3 check you have to take the plunge
at some point sometimes you're not going to
win the game just by you know maneuvering a lot
but i feel like this is still so good for him
yeah i can't complain about this but
queen g5 it's going to be a winning move
now this is the more i look at this the more
i realize he actually hasn't relinquished any
of his advantage oh bishop takes c6 knight
f5 excuse me hell no knight of five for you
wow okay but knight g2 kicks the rook away yeah
rook word wait a second rookie four i guess and
he keeps the attack on a3 and the h3 yeah attack
everywhere and you just have full control over
yeah you didn't play g5 at some point i wouldn't
do that right now well actually i would have
considered g5 there thanks but i like the fact
that he's establishing a pass fun he can drop
the queen to d6 and then go for c5 also as well as
obviously and the good thing about c5 is it brings
the a pawn under the bishop's protection very very
true it becomes a protected pass pawn from a long
range piece so h6 is trying to look at g5 also
giving his king an escape from the back rank not
that that was needed just yet but always good to
have always needed oh gosh g5 tempe with knight h5
crunch not he's gonna go c5 and just smash through
the center you mentioned double pawns being often
underestimated robert this is another instance of
that where he can play c6 and the other pawn again
undermines the pawn on d5 no rush with that
though he goes a3 drives that pawn through
this is completely winning for him completely
winning he's gonna have to make a couple more
accurate moves though yeah and just like the
bishop came alive to defend the a pawn c5 to c4
will open up the queen to the defense and then uh
make this pawn on d5 even weaker right white needs
to somehow protect that pawn with another pawn
that's not happening now e3 falls fall and then i
think g5 is going to come at the right moment but
he's got to watch for knight h5 if he does play g5
i think it's still works he have rookie 2 in
the end of those variations but yes just he goes
rook a4 he gets his behind his pass pawn there's
good end game technique in this position not sure
if it was best but how can you fault that move
anyway no you uh you can't and and uh you know
all roads lead to rome here but but you want
to be careful about overusing that expression
in chess sometimes you get too comfortable and
again we talked about this all of a sudden the
wind gets a little bit more difficult but he is
banking on his a-pawn which i think is possible
so are not doing what he can though to activate
his pieces seek counter play against flex king
he wants an e4 e5 you get e3 to e5 in one move he
would have some serious chances just to open up
the king but too slow yep and he goes king h2
trying to tuck his king away preemptively the 20
seconds is what concerns me a little bit uh for [
__ ] hall because if he if he gives white any hope
wait 96 96 queen rookie 7 maybe just like i would
have tried that just because of the time situation
now he drops his queen back and that just seems
like an admission of you know nothing's going
well for me here and for a new holiday mission
hey i probably should have played a little bit
differently in the last couple of moves
i my advantage is still huge the bishop
on c4 protects a2 uh that's you know the
essential pawn there the rook and a1 is
stuck being passive and just defending the
square and thus how do you defend e3 rook f3
yeah queen e5 rook b8 i mean
bishop takes d5 you can even play
and there's just so many moves here
we need one yeah so this is queen e5
right after the e3 pawn sliding in with
queen e4 rook be b1 is a plan as well
no funny queen e3 thank you yep he's gonna i'm
taking that g5 also possible i was looking at g5
rook to ba you keep mentioning that move too many
yeah i mean there's no hurry he's just enjoying
himself here and and you can play entirely at
your leisure why there's no counter player okay
three is going after another pawn and if rocket
feed then g5 forces the trade of queens right
winning position so rook f3 there's g5 kicking the
knight the queen e2 check to force the queens off
yep we need four same idea but queen
of two i guess he wants queen b1
yeah why not you can't believe he's thinking about
it he's going to play oh my gosh he's just so
that's clinical that is very clinical she can't
move and if the queen out queen comes to g1 you
take it and then you finally go rook via rook b1
or g5 or one of a million moves what a game here
to and this opening uncharacteristically robert
sarnot doesn't usually get in such trouble with
the white pieces out of the opening allowing
e4 e3 you know you spotted the tactic that may
have won a pete rookie two would have won
the queen directly but this is also good
well look at this this is just tied to hand
and foot last breaths here rook takes d5 but
this is cosmetic even queen you can allow queen
of stuff to allow it but he doesn't yeah very
very smart not to allow it yeah he just shuts this
down entirely and it's over it is indeed and that
means that he takes a 5-3 lead heading into the
time patrolling what a mistake by sarna in this
last game i mean the opening was really just that
so questionable yes this we've seen before and his
first i guess error if you will was not throwing
in this g4 move because when you get this position
if the queen's on g6 you don't have e5 you've been
calling for that e5 clamoring for a time after
time yeah just allow this pawn to e3 destruction
immediately responded in a big way and uh
that's definitely a rough end for sarnath but
he's got to put things in perspective it's a
two-point game this has been an incredibly high
level final we've gotten everything we've asked
for and then some and i'm sure we will again
in the three-minute portion but first coffee
well i'll let you grab your coffee we'll
all take a little breather and when we
return we will have the three minute
plus one second increment portion of
this junior speed chess championship
final brought to you by chess.com and
chesskid.com
so
and we return to the junior speed chess
championship final between nihal sarin and alexis
saranac and it was predicted that nihal sarin
would make his way to the final and be the player
that makes his way to the speeches championship
because that's what's at stake in addition to the
prize money as we see the predictions brought to
us by chess goals daniel nihal sarah was expected
to beat sam sevion but sarina knocked sevin out
earlier do you think that's going to hold up
is nihal sarin going to be our champion well based
on the way that the five-minute portion has gone i
think there's every reason to believe that uh
he's played incredibly but obviously uh we've
seen the kind of displays that sauron has put
on he's not in bad form today so things could
turn around in in an instant in a single move
i think this is going to be really close and
it's been an amazing match and but before we
have left off just a couple more things here
yeah you know the chess goals just smart just
bringing us these predictions it's an innovative
12-week data-driven premium study plan to help you
stay focused and reach your goals you can use the
coupon jscc to save 25 on your purchase so
you use the command goals in chat enjoy it
it's a great product but alas we are about to
have liftoff in this jscc match-up nihal saron
goes into the three-minute portion up a couple
points in the match but alexis serrano if anybody
is capable of uh mounting a comeback i believe he
is certainly able to do so absolutely he is and uh
we've seen that his time management has been more
than savvy uh and uh in the three-minute portion
nihal is going to have to modify his strategy a
little bit if he's blitz beast obviously he knows
that now he doesn't need me telling him but uh
some of those critical moments robert he's going
to have to speed up his decision making slightly
he will and we have a different style of position
it is catalan like in nature because the bishop
on g2 staring down towards the queen side so that
bishop is just generally speaking the best piece
on the board but black is captured on c4 down now
white was queen to c2 i know some lines include
b5 trying to keep this pawn others say hey take
that pawn back nothing i can do about it i'm going
to be extra solid and that's the latter approach
by sir and i is giving the pawn up but no this is
definitely he hasn't equalized there's no way this
is equal this is this is a catalan dream in fact
i think this is this is quite bad for him normally
if you give up a pawn like that you want to get b6
bishop b7 already in he takes the approach a very
solid approach and maybe he wants to play e5 in
some of these positions yep he does play e5 yeah
the problem that i think you and i are kind of
hinting at is that the bishop on c8 you know it's
typically not a great piece but that's why you
play e5 right open up that diagonal and there is
a pawn majority for white from the now from the
d3 h files maybe it will transition to the e
through the h files and black has a pawn majority
from the a through the c files three on two but
black's pawns are stuck in place they are not able
to push through because white is so well developed
here and that should leave white with a small plus
but nihal down almost 20 seconds already yep he is
and uh now he's deciding what to take with uh yeah
i would take with the knight yeah i definitely
don't want that isolated pawn i like what alexi
has done here in the last couple of moves at first
i was beginning to think robert his position was
really dubious but now he's gone e5 i still think
he's slightly worse and i think nihal is very good
at squeezing an advantage out of these positions
but by and large i think there's no
uh global problems with his position
and uh speaking of problems i my coffee is five
feet away i have to get up and get it so i'm gonna
give you the wheel for three seconds here all
right well that sounds like an issue for sure
and you saw a trade of knights and e5 the queen
comes there but look at this queen hitting b7
so black in terms of the quality of his pieces
doing perfectly fine in fact the bishop is now
developed it was stuck behind the wall of
pawns when it was in c8 now it's outside
any kind of pawn chain out in the open knight
on six queen on e5 rook and d7 everything nice
and solid here so dania i see that you're back
i'm only just starting to talk to you my friend
but oh no g4 f4 f5 i was about to say that black
did a great job of getting out of any danger but
you walked into a loss of a piece what did i do
it was me getting up and get getting the coffee
that's what that's what made him blunder now does
he take on g4 is that the lesser evil but that rob
that's that's not that's not nearly enough is
it no it most certainly is not this bishop and
that's even more precise i think up for first in
order to eliminate eliminate those possibilities
yeah that's true because if you played g4 earlier
and the bishop was already here the queen could
come to age five but now the queen does not get
to stay and try to be a menacing piece on the
king side here comes g4 thank you so much for
your bishop g4 bishop takes ponzi's knight g4
i could see how that could scare nihal off he's
wearing an e3 and a mating attack maybe knight f5
here should be preferred um he's got a minute here
and i don't mean to sound like a broken record but
again this becomes a little bit more significant
in a three-minute portion when you have less time
to begin with so one very precise move required
here i'm thinking rook f3 is also possible
queen h4 and then well you could do nothing you
could allow queen h2 that could look could seem
unthinkable but it's not always as dangerous
as it seems not sure though what is the most
accurate way here yeah because knight f3 would
drop the e3 pawn you don't want to lose a third
one he plays your move knight f5 queen f6
i guess his e4 yeah but i was afraid of g6
yeah because i was trying to go queen g3 if i
had enough time but your g6 move says not so fast
okay knight e3 simply he wants to trade the
knights oh but a queen before this rook d1
giving up the knight and he gives
the away e5 here in fermento maybe
because you don't want to do a b2 is what you're
trying to i'm not sure about that i'm not sold on
the fact that giving up b2 is such a bad thing
i mean you could give it up and go rook up too
sure but that is a third pawn and it is
yeah okay it gives up b2 and i see the
the bar start sinking there so probably
yeah e5 would have been better and now
he goes f5 see that's something like what i was
thinking he goes directly for the attack sorry
serrano traits queens as you say what is that
three queens are gone yeah and uh well nihal could
put the pawn on f6 that's one of the ideas that
gives him that those long he still has something
resembling an attack and now you can't take the
pawn because bishop h3 oh nice that's a nasty idea
nihal found that very quickly you did rooks would
be in a line in the light square so that would be
bishop h3 and actually this is so essential to
white's winning chances creating a clear pass on
in rook f7 taking a page out of your book the
pawn on a2 is the same color as the bishop
yes for sure and also he has determined that
that end game after the trade of both rooks
on the 7th is going to be winning for him which
i think it is yes so and if rookie six you have
that would not be very good because rook one
takes b7 and thank you for a massive attack oh
that is nasty so what can you so i think you have
to do yeah i think you have to take and go king
six because the the bishop against uh pawn's end
game is the king is going to limit yeah easily
the connected passers black's going to end up in
zuma he's gonna have to give up both funds i don't
see that happening for black he goes for it well
amazing right i feel like it is but maybe there's
something we're not taking into account well okay
so what in order to win obviously the white king
needs to go after this a pawn so somehow you
know black's king can't do anything why can
you go a4 leave a bishop on e8 or whatever wait a
sec though is there a way for me to get over here
oh and then just a you can't take my pawns are
linked yes oh my goodness that's a great it's
an amazing defensive idea by cernov because
anything king a3 bishop b5 the problem for
example you can't take this pawn because
black just pushes this one all the way through
that's amazing i mean and i've we've seen
these ideas before many times it's like the
pawns are chained together the moment the king
takes uh the bishop becomes overloaded with the
task of defending a2 and stopping h4 it's a draw
yeah all you do now is king b2 pawn a3 and then
just go king a1 king b1 uh b2 whatever back and
forth and as we keep talking about you take on g6
you'll see exactly this play out you give one's
gonna go all the way to h1 all the way to h1 and
there's the draw wow and that is wow that's
that's a very very strong defensive effort by
sir now that move rook f7 it was played quickly
a very understandable choice by nihal it seemed
losing but because of this very specific idea and
robert here we have another one of these lines
we have it once more we'll see if alexei
has learned his lesson during the break
you know checked his prep he does include g4
now there's none of this e5 stuff very important
distinction and i do see some people saying oh you
know nihal doesn't need a you know we don't need
to worry about any house time he doesn't need to
worry about it because of just win with them two
seconds i actually think that the last game even
though he didn't he of course didn't lose it but
he probably should have been given more winning
chances than he did you know by playing rook f7
he didn't have enough time to really calculate
all the consequences and we obviously didn't
know that it was a draw so easily serrano says
yeah actually i got this under control but right
i looked at this when i was 14 and then led by led
by gary caspara vladimir kramnik i just think that
nihal does need to leave himself a little bit
more time so he can convert positions like that
especially because sarana is never going to go
down without a huge fight right he never is and
uh neither of these players is now we've seen this
be before this is the position where i propose d5
black is worse here i i mean i'm not sure what
it is neil sees in this position maybe i mean
f6 prepares e5 i suppose what's that he did last
time like his bishop somehow came around to g6 but
that's because sarnath went queen c2 very right
in that game which is probably premature yeah and
here he goes rook c1 he turns the dial up exchange
second coming um no probably too early sorry no
i'm interested in it i don't think it works
there's always knight f4 for black yeah i'm
definitely intrigued okay so it as is i'm sure now
but queen c2 here is also possible something like
that but that way that gives up on so somehow
nihal concretely because of that f4 square it
seems like he's got um pretty good chances here i
have i stand corrected yeah something's not going
right for sarna in this opening i think he should
change it yeah i agree and i also think you should
castle here i think you should just he should
just move his king out of the center oh that h4
okay so queen f7 yeah queen f7 and then niho is
also probably considering queen e8 but i'm not
sure what benefits that contains he goes green f7
although the the bar did not like queen of seven
oh i see the difference i see the difference okay
so with the queen on f7 white can play e4 and d5
very quickly as just one option with the queen on
e8 you don't get e4 in because i could take on d4
and then your pawn e4 is pinned okay but what
about knight f4 here okay knight takes c5 i like
knight f4 i feel like while white is still on
castles you can try to generate these chances
star now still doesn't castle but now something
tells me he's stabilized the boat a little bit
the bishop here it's all about the bishop
heading this is good for white yeah 100 so i'm
trying something knight to d4 to be three true
that would be a big pain so you can play e3 that
does soften up some of your light squares but e3
it takes away um the d4 square from that knight
what else can we play here just
worried about alexis internet here
oh wow he's a red bar but you know okay
i was going to link that to the emails
are we sure about this i most definitely am
not sure about this he was knight b6 quickly
look at that d4 square crunch i i'm shocked
that he played that i am too that is
somewhere i mean who are the positional kappa
blanca uh vladimir kramnik they're not very
happy at this point but um i'm going to give
alexi the benefit of the doubt here he's uh you
know he's a lot better at making these judgments
than i have so we'll see what he does here queen
c through rook ft1 maybe maybe he's banking on
sort of the immediate activity of his pieces
perhaps and i guess there's a knight f5 jump that
could be a little frustrating at some point but
something about this seems like it did not go
the way he wanted to you could take on ether
at any moment to get rid of the bishop pair but
perhaps black doesn't actually have as much as i
thought just based on initial instinct like knight
c4 it's such a good piece but what next right and
our production team our wonderful production team
reminds us that alexi is the trooper that he is
is playing a match from a hotel room uh because
he's playing currently the russian higher league
which is incredibly strong over-the-board
event actually so he's making time for this
final uh kudos to him but that could be
impacting his connection a little bit
yeah so you know the background is very different
but yeah where's that wooden sauna wall yeah i
know think one of the same thing the steam room
he's now it's all over the board none of that
in the background but he still looks focused he's
still of course playing his heart out and he just
pushed his pawn to f4 so speaking of weakening
moves it looks aggressive but it could also
leave your king on g1 extremely vulnerable he's
demanding a lot from his thesis here he's he's
stretching his resources thin but that could
pay off um bishop b3 nihal sticks his bishop
on another outpost look at that knight on d4 the
bishop on b3 he can also go b6 c5 and support the
knight i i mean all of my positional instincts are
telling me that black is in fantastic shape here
i would certainly concur with that bishop d3 what
doesn't stop b6 c5 you just pointed that idea out
and what is white's idea where do you go from
here yeah i mean you're again he's created so
many weaknesses now nihol with 30 seconds or b6
indeed played i like this idea maybe you go e5 yup
oh so you're hoping to get an attack on this
at some point you've done so much you might as
well go the full nine yards that bfb knight f5
ideas well there's also a queen e4 hitting h7
and threatening queen aids you actually have to
be careful and again the time c5 by knee hull he
ignores it queen e4 what does knee hold want to
do their g6 but then you're checking that looks
scary there's also they're also f5 ideas after g6
like let me just try to crash through rookie seven
no fear g5s maybe g5 is there f5 is like that
shuts things down i agree okay sometimes you can
get away with things like that but not here so
knight of three out of three the tension is so
the position might look sort of tame it might look
balanced but it's laden with tension filled to the
brim in eight seconds here we go okay so he does
play g6 but now now i don't like that because it
doesn't mean we can see the position has
gotten rid of that pesky knight on d4 that
lightens his load by quite taking five f5 is just
too bad yeah i thought you could take an e5 like
h6 though that also was available that also
didn't look good queen c 40 hall going after
white's king sir is going going take on g6 but uh
queen d4 check oh gosh oh he takes the bishop oh
he attacks the brook wow wondered wow it's look
at sorry no he's just shaking h6 would have been
much stronger your move because that would have
threatened checkmate yes it would f8 and g6 we
will uh bring up the analysis board real quick
here uh but look at the players queen c4 wow
you can't believe it you can't believe
it you can at this moment he could take
on g6 right away but queen h6 it threatens
a rook f8 mate it threatens the pawn on g6
and maybe nihal will survive this it just i
don't see the way to uh it looks just very
dangerous yeah it does that threat of queen
fate just put this quickly to screen on the
wrong square and yeah immediately seizing
the opportunity we have another look at this
i am going to stay very remember that game in
serena versus john where they had crazy theory
for like 20 moves this is another one of those
vienna games i have no clue what's going on here
help me out robert i'm just gonna go through the
moves so we can show everybody one of these lines
where bishop back to d2 and now sarona takes an
e4 queen g4 hits the knight hits g7 says here
take my two pieces for your rook but your king
is in the center so we get to the live board here
oh my goodness how do we evaluate this so let's do
a quick material account two minor pieces and no
not any bonds too many pieces for rook that's
clean so that's the exact material imbalance
the king is on e7 not thrilled to be there you
have to keep your queen in line with the f5 square
idea in that regard g4 following knight five could
be something and you pick queen to g7 so why would
you remove your queen from h8 was there some kind
of threat oh g4 g4 g queen g6 knight f5k e8 queen
queen d4 yeah is g4 devastating that looks
like it's devastating what does black even do
that could just be checkmate looks very tempting
it does and i'm sure nihal is calculating it
the question did sarah miss it or is he
seeing something there that we're missing
there's probably something deeper there there
probably is he's moving very quickly so he's
for it's a bluff and he hulk calls it i think
we're about to see let's take a look at his face
yeah he kind of braced his eyebrows there i think
he missed it okay but he played his responsibility
yeah maybe not so queen d4 was played but the
barge dropped so there must have been something
that was even better maybe rook d4 weirdly enough
like that way you hit the right queen stays defend
you can double your rooks in the d file and i
guess the point that alexi is thinking is hey
you know what give me that check on g7 come after
me i've got everything defended he's got the d7
bishop defended he's got the c4 knight defendant
it seems that nihal doesn't really have any entry
points he does probably have perpetual though
sardar could get run his king to d8 even here
i guess he can take on h5 simply and
then knight f4 knight d5 becomes an idea
practically speaking this is so hard to play
in a blitz game robert yeah it certainly is
and if black can stabilize it's a very big if
bishop c6 will happen and then it's white's
king that can get in trouble but that's a
very far ways away heads are gonna roll here
and uh whose head is gonna roll so queen
g5 i'm tempted to play f4 but then queen
c5 trading the queen so i do not want to
trade queens i'm tempted to play knight f4
justin and then knight d5 i really i know
that's a very sort of telegraphed thing like
you know like jimmy garoppolo's football
pass that he winds up for 10 minutes and then
throws an interception but uh knight g3 so similar
kind of concept he's coming to f5 but there's very
little the black could do maybe queen c5 your
move robert knight five kings king d8 how do
you exactly chase that king down which is escaping
to c7 that king's really just going on a journey
though there's queen f6 check ideas which may
drop f7 so like queens if your queen goes too far
what a brave guy f6
a7 could even take on a seven exactly i know that
you know i know but why not you can take
that what is shock remember alexander
i certainly do three puns queen takes a7 there
is bishop c6 so you actually have to be careful
you think you're not rocking 495 etc i'm with
you i mean i'm with you that queen seven looks
like a hanging pawn i'm just you have to
be certain before you take that one because
that i'm not certain it just gives black that
very needed tempo to bring a bishop on the strong
diagonal i don't like what you're indicating about
about what i am and i'm not certain about i don't
know if i want to compensate with you thankfully
this is the finality of the speech championship
so what what can white do he's spending a lot of
time he's done yes he's vacillating over there
that's exactly what he's thinking about knight f5
is tempting as well with king f7 that's the point
of f6 is actually a brilliant move h4 also came
to mind but that actually just sends the queen
to if here he goes but he's getting too long
taking that now he did way too long i agree and
c6 maybe come back to d4 and then 95. oh my
goodness knight f3 i keep forgetting about that
it just feels like you're inviting me in it's a
warm welcome to dinner thank you so much daniel
you're welcome robert you're always welcome
but i'm really good at ordering pizza i'm
just gonna tell you i'm serious
no like these light squares are
really an issue and we're talking
about a while but now it's two pawns
and a rook for the two miners it's less about the
material and more so about the weak squares how
does he stop 95 that's an incredibly devastating
idea the 94 trying to get rid of the bishop i
would not take that knight that's for sure i'd
play queen b5 maybe just throw my queen that way
queen and then queen d4 maybe but again
95. geez keeps recurring and then actually
if you're not careful this knight from f8
can go to g6 and the e5 or h4 right this g4
pawn would like to go back to g3 or even g2 to
help the white king ah maybe queen b5 he wants a4
ah and queen takes a four queen c5 and queen takes
c4 i see you with your tactics they are nice and
sharp that was a nice tactic though yeah that that
would be great i do think that watch this happen
wow that would actually here if a4 here it is so
watch this happen or queen b6 queen b6 is probably
the best just right trade the queen's 56 queen
b696 96 now oh my gosh if takes knight c8 check
i guess that also looks good yeah you could
have moved the rook away after 96 but wow
i like queen b6 i got excited there because
then knight f5 check uh wait isn't that wasn't
the night just hanging on c4 yeah wasn't what
are we missing there robert i i don't know
but here he's going to take d6 take e6 and nihal
again look at the clock that he's managing and
he's just he's impervious to it and that's made
only eight zero noise there's no way you want to
queen e5 you only went wow unbelievable and
look at how quickly he turned this around
this idea of a four robber to find
it with almost no time on the clock
is incredible you found it he found it you
both are i'm sitting in my comfort zone
i was like what is rook takes e5 oh my gosh we
have to show that oh my lance oh my gosh there
was just oh my sorry there's rook a1 and rook h1
m8 you can stop it that's unbelievable you missed
checkmate you did oh that's so unfortunate
for him it is it is that was a huge chance
to turn things around and we're going to get a
live automatic response oh my goodness robert
he still has like an outside chance to hold
this game but it does but the pawns are too
strong queen c3 if two seconds anything can happen
but the queen's gonna fork the rook on e5 yeah
queen e5 check that's it wow he mischecked me oh
gosh my goodness and does he i mean i don't know
if he realizes it uh it's not probably not the
sort of thing you realize in retrospect oh my god
i'm like i'm wheeling myself out of the room here
i just can't believe it i can't believe it either
that's crazy because when you put the bishop on
c6 you have to be attuned to these kinds of things
and it was such a it was a very natural sacrifice
because black had two minor pieces for the queen
and so as soon as you give back some of your extra
material to make your life easier he unfortunately
made the game lost but you know neil he escapes
it now he's up four points and with 36 minutes
left in the three plus one at some point sauron
just has to start winning because the bullet is
favoring neil yeah and we know nihal's bullet
is just something out of the stuff of legend but
essentially i i've been observing in these matches
that four i think is sort of the magic x factor
number robert it's completely anecdotal but i feel
like uh when the lead is at four you win a game
okay it gets manageable you lose the lead gets the
half half a decade mark that's pretty extensive i
feel like this is the important game and look at
the odds yes those are not favoring alexi let me
tell you no they're not in it's because nihal's
bullet skills are pretty much second to hikaru
maybe there are a couple other people who can
claim that they are better than him but not many
yeah no from the onset of this match that was
the expectation they were going to bring up the
chess goals and smart chess predictions uh it was
nihal dominating in the one plus one the quickest
time patrol because he's just exceptional and it
was supposed to be according to prediction that
sarana would get out to a lead in the early stages
that has not happened so it's been all nihal in
the match i'm looking at the live bullet rankings
of the people logged in on chess.com there's two
people ahead of nihal in bullet he's 32.79 you
want to hear who they are on twitch and picaro
so it's one person to account exactly got it
that's like when uh i was watching the uh us
team uh play the basketball well play basketball
in the olympics and they asked the coach of uh
i think spain or something well who's the three
most dangerous teams the spanish basketball team
will be competing against you said there will i'll
name three the usa the united states and the u.s
hall not many who can compete with him in bullet
this is the time for alexi to do something for
sure and you know we see in this position right
now it is even material the king on h1 you just
dropped over there there's some ideas of rook g1
i guess but are we really believing in that i mean
why king h1 there well because it's russian
movie no russian noise shifts the king away
yeah i don't like this pawn structure it's
just too many weaknesses and 94 is possible
here getting that bishop uncontested i know
it's going to be blocked in by the d-pawn but
man if that d-pawn moves there will be hell to
pay for sure and the special can go to c8 and
wrap itself around and actually it starts on that
journey just now but what's interesting about this
donya is the c3 pawn the a3 pawns split over on
the queen side and nihal doesn't go for that he
said first reroutes the bishop and watch out for
bishop a4 wouldn't exchange uh but wouldn't you
go after the c3 pawn i would i would but i'd be
a little bit worried about the g file g that's g5
no i know i'm kidding it's actually
probably not that bad of a move but
actually yeah it's one of those things maybe
king fade in g5 you try to turn that on white
these ideas can be very unpleasant psychologically
you feel like man my opponent's helping me
but you don't see the reputation now yes white
threatening bishop takes d5 probably he is
you got to be brave to take that you really must
but that knight takes d4 bishop f5 and if e4 takes
d5 hmm okay so bishop d5 knight hd4 knight d4 cd4
bishop so he doesn't do it again knight c5 and now
i would go after that pod maybe knight a4 rook c8
okay there's knight a4 and i guess rooksy one is
he plays qui he's moving this queen around he does
yeah and he all keeps moving the night around
the response so queen takes d5 can i get away
with that bishop a4 yeah there's an exchange but
again look at the knight the queen of the dance
well the the dance doesn't look so fun
anymore for white because no it sounds
very weak it's a dance of death
especially if that knight gets
the v3 of the bishop to a4 or the knight
to c3 oh my gosh we're gonna say dancing
so what to do i feel like black should have
some pres like okay can i go knight e4 right
before yeah bishop takes c4 i feel like that's a
worse version because the queen then comes to h5
and i can't i need to get my bishop like
on the right side of this pawn chain like
i need to have my bishop on e4 and again
the time situation but knight back to a4
what about c4 can you play that we oh yeah queen
before the the queen is defended very importantly
yeah i thought you could try that but yeah i was
thinking about some sacrifice wait 16 seconds for
black where did all the time go it evaporated now
what exactly does alexis do i would double on the
g file you can also take on e6 so you take
with the pawn to protect you yeah yeah yeah
you slam a rook in there but there is you're
giving up an attack on c3 oh yeah that is true
and if you move the book to g1 here also
well then white is giving up the c3 square
okay taking on d5 i guess queen t4 is a fork look
at that noticing the undefended pieces and bishop
g4 is also in the mix okay the wheels are coming
off here for knee hall you're right because he's
bringing the knight back to e6 but he had to
give up a couple pawns here on the king's side
of queen takes h6 but this is a chance knight
p3 oh but then quick before check oh wow good
find good good realization but you know nihal's
going to he's got to fight tooth and nail he's not
never easy to bring down i mean this already is
getting better from black because you cannot move
the rook the other way you lose your bishop with
check and if you take on e4 i can take with the
queen trade them off and say hey good luck to you
you can even take the pawn but i would take the
queen trade off those points 94 is a great move
with six seconds on the clock and this is alexi
just has to find a way to win this game and yet a
lion's share of his advantage has just evaporated
you know it's funny i i really do think time
and time again that nihal is in trouble and
then he's always proving me wrong that hey yep
any time more than zero seconds or nothing but
three okay he gets that move off and rookie one
watch out for some rooks he said c7 yeah yeah but
now c3 is not under attack at least not the same
way bro and alexa goes that rook g8 was possible
check there's rook to check and then you take
the wow so that's the idea animal right now and
then a b and rook c one maybe but you're
always going to move you're obviously one
more six six be six that's three points oh my
gosh but he's going after blight spawns white
spawns are very weak here king f3 king g3 c and
f3 if rook c4 but then you take on b4 oh he's
just trying to give him oh this is a really nice
move king of three and that's taking up seven this
should be winning for white now two puns to the
good oh and you're also gonna mate this king 57
be careful don't take yeah because you
don't break a big check as king g3 but
brigade check is now the threat so he puts
his work on five you can't leave the last
round i know it sounds crazy but you've
got to always watch for stalemate ideas
but this is fighting to the last drop of blood is
nihal but this is winning pretty straightforwardly
yeah rookie six the pawns just pushing themselves
together and it's winning and no reason not to
spend a couple more seconds if you're in the
hall you're up four points every every second
counts but there's still a lot of time but donna
this is the first time that neil's time travel
has cost him because he's been in the midst of
time scramble after time scrambling wait a second
no this has to be winning this is a hundred
percent his wedding check uh yeah e6 okay continue
sorry yeah you worried me i was looking at it
like wait is there any way this isn't winning
okay and the king yeah no this is winning this
is winning yeah if the pods were on the g and h
files that's a different story for sure right but
i rudely interrupted you you were saying this is
the first time the holstein pressure has costed
him i agree i mean uh costed that's not yeah costs
but anyway the point is that finally alexi can
feel like he's in this match because it must be so
frustrating when you are just kind of cruising in
many games but you can't score the full point you
can't now so quick on his feet i mean he's able
to generate these chances with two seconds on
the clock it's a crazy but uh this is a big
game for alexi it shrinks the lead to three
and uh this next game is just as important he's
gonna have the black pieces let's see if he can
shrink this lead further and half it okay
so it's seven at four and a half and will we
get a repetition of the lines that
we've been seeing we have a maroon file
okay okay i always like the matches and i'm
a little biased in favor of that different
openings different types of positions and can
i ask your permission for something robert
i made the mistake of bringing some chocolate
here and i have this little chocolate bar not
a bar it's a square and i really want to get into
it but can i mute myself for one second and just
get rid of this while you talk you certainly can
appreciate how considerate you were there um i'm
a little jealous because you didn't send me a
chocolate bar but that's okay this is amazing
this line is quite sharp in fact because black
it can steal this a2 pawn white has the better
center here but the uh you know whoa queen bearing
b3 okay you defend the pawn so this is typical
more pawns in the center an extra pawn for white
but black has the queen side pawn majority so
in the immediate position white should be favored
but in the long term in the prospects the end game
black is the one who should be happy because of
the oh but here i think white is just crashing
through like d5 immediately yeah and in the
grunfeld there's a couple of interesting things
to point out one of them is that i always point
this out the upon majority for black on the kick
on the queen side right it's two on one it favors
black in a pawn end game because then upon enemy
it's gonna be easier to create an outside passer
but but in a middle game a queenless middle game
white's got that central pressure so as long as he
can keep the pieces on the board sticker rook on
c7 keep the c file dominance white is totally in
control of the game yes indeed and because pieces
the longer the center they have more opportunities
from central squares that's why having pawns in
the center is good it restricts the pieces and
here knight b4 are you really going after the a2
pawn can i throw rook c7 in to start hitting your
bishop hitting your b7 pawn threatening bishop c5
which hits your knight on before in your pawn
e7 that just looks good for white to me totally
and i'm just a little distracted because i'm
discussing my chocolate choices with the chat here
but yeah no rook c7 i mean the pawns start just
getting mowed down and vacuumed up by the rook
bishop c5 now but wait a second yeah knight takes
a2 bishop takes d8 bishop takes e7 and then we
almost then i lose it reminds me i don't
know if i have time to share the story um
the one time i got told off at a chess game just
once by my former well coach and amazing player
grandmaster gregory kaidanov he would host a lot
of u.s chess schools in kentucky where he lives
and one camp i there was this inside joke among
the participants of the camp we would share a line
that we knew was bad only to say and i lose at the
end of it and for some reason that was funny to us
and i took that joke way too far and at the la
on the last day i kept sharing these lines and
saying and i was and kaidana finally caught on
to it he's like he tells me in russian in the
middle of the campaign one more time and we're
gonna have a serious talk and i'm gonna have a
serious talk with your mother after the class and
like okay okay okay okay and i got beat red yeah
yeah anyway i was in a troll you thought i was
in the troll all the trolls out there you're
wrong yeah you you're the example made and you
deserved it clearly what is happening in this
game oh because i think i lose yeah the hell
is down to about a minute there are two pawns
that can be captured b7 and e7 but is this that
kind of like typical grunfeld compensation where
even though you're down something in this case
a pawn that your pieces are working well yeah
i mean with the grip with the green field it's
one of those openings similarly to the king's
indian robert where it doesn't matter how bad
your position is optically you're always going
to have certain chances certain counter play
on one of the flanks and here we see knight c3
he can try to go for bishop b5 that knight on
b7 is a little bit stuck but it's got plenty
of evacuation squares now where does the
bishop go after d3 it goes to d3 definitely
now bishop b5 getting prepared though i'm telling
you that knight on c3 in combination with the rook
on c8 it poses some difficulty to play yes because
once the bishop gets to be fine with the a pawn
the a3 pawn feels like more of a target the united
c3 stops this rook from going to c1 there will be
92 check ideas so not easy for you know to figure
this out he is up a pawn but he's down a minute
and 15 seconds again oh and bishop d4 was an
idea there even oh nice bishop d for trying to
remove the guard yeah the rook on c one watch
out ninety two he stops yeah watch out now the
rook can see it is undefeated rook c4 meets with
well rook c4 f3 even have a revolution never okay
directly yeah i'm attacking this and i like it
but bishop c5 maybe oh we're going to count one
by one here yeah so yeah alexi wisely is spending
his time right now this is a big moment yeah to
rook aid rook b8 rook c4 you guys wrote b8 to hit
the knight and then you can take e4 if he wants it
yeah and uh knight c6 is what
nihal's aiming for wait a minute
he had knight c6 knight take c7 check by the way
bishop h6 is there some kind of b4 at some point
i can't take him before because rook check would
turn the two right and by the way there is a cool
idea by by knee hall instead of rookie 7 to go
knight c6 and then take on e7 right but this is
also very good i mean he's going for the activity
this is looking very bad now knight c6 he wants
knight takes d5 but even there we go rook d7 i
like knight c6 here for oh but knight 63 is check
knight c6 knight d5 and then
rook moves the knight takes e3
four seconds he's gotta move okay and he missed
it i think so 97 check and just trying to make
a draw oh he doesn't have a 93 that's the key
yeah now 93 and then rookie does alexi see it
yeah but this is an extra pawn for black all of a
sudden but he's going to win it back oh but rook
a8 and all of a sudden you can take off e3 so 97
the knight back to c6 you can't take on a3 because
rook d8 will be mate the activity of white's
pieces i think garrett is clearly better for black
yeah no he's got an attempt here he takes on
h2 he wins the pawn he does and and the time
advantage again makes it very hard to defend oh
my goodness rook a1 do you always a bishop g1
check but i've moved the bishop back to d6 h5
okay it's the obligatory move in all end games
it does feel that way often and a note to
everybody the bishop does not match the corner h1
so if i can straight off the f g pawns we got this
robert this is where i get stressed out oh gotta
move you gotta move forward he's going bishop g3
bishop g3 oh here's work up to check kenny seven
or king g7 rook f2 rook takes g2 thank you for a
pawn he literally was showing zero zero zero but
now black is simply just winning on the position
yeah that pawn is too good bishop anywhere
is your e1 maybe yeah and we can see he blended
upon no h3o h3 knight sixty-five h2 rookie
that's a huge fun i'll give you the next knight
of strats but he untraps the knight f3 look at me
all maneuvering you're defending incredible wow
i mean it's still hard to defend though he had
that though in the bag and now niho pushing his
pawn up the rook is activated he's threatening e6
so king seven and then he bring the king up
bishop b2 okay bishop c5 no work a7 check but
i thought the bishop was going to b2 it hit
the e5 pawn because this way seven each game
be careful yeah don't take on e5 because
you dropped that fight the rook on a
dark square also worries me okay never
mind so king c6 g6 94 check don't play
f6 f6 he's got to find f6 it's a truck
unbelievable wow just wow unbelievable and for
nihal he can just waste more time i would decline
it and sir not you can just see the frustration
he he knows it's a draw but he can't believe it i
mean he was he just had that in the back yeah and
he's wasting more time from this three minute
portion we know that nihal is the favorite in
the bullet and i mean nihal in his time trouble he
has really struggled at points over the board but
the results are still in his favor the man is
unbelievable he finds you know chance after
chance he complicates it his time was dipping to
point zero one second and he found the chance to
win a pawn uh that was incredible defense and
now uh wait a second now robert careful is in
the wrong corner your king is supposed to be
in the other corner this is actually going to
be very very hard to defend well it's still
a draw but yeah it's going to take forever
it is you know we talk about this it's not like
unethical or anything to play this he has every
right to and he should uh bleed the clock because
this is also easy to blunder him yeah and he gets
the king to the right corner the important part
of this end game is that the king for white
cannot create opposition because you can check
it off when it's on a dark square so oh no oh no
wow and neil laughed you see all that he laughed
a little bit he did and sarah smiling as well he's
just like what do i have to do oh my gosh in my
lance oh it's just crazy i'm gonna bring up the
old the last game very quickly i need to analyze
just something to show people where sorana blew
his advantage because way way way back when
yep i don't even know what move here was h4
knight g5 and if you play bishop e1 there's a
big difference that when the knight comes to
f3 you could still play h3 because you don't have
access to this h4 square so if 91 i just push to
h2 and i get a queen it's not gonna be the easiest
win in the world but that way your pawn could go
wait there's rook h4 i'm missing the rook h4 move
what so i bought it as myself so wait a second oh
wait i have an idea oh my oh it doesn't work i
thought something crazy but no maybe just like a
any other move like rook a red okay
two yeah just go somewhere you know
something like this way more difficult than i
expected i thought it was gonna be easily winning
but actually there are tricks that allow one even
f6 to kick the knight yeah i see the the bar still
agrees that so is this winning position oh bishop
covers c7 that's that's very important but it's
easy to assume your opponent you know with no
time is just going to let the pawn through but
uh not nehal oh my gosh i mean that's the
thing right even in post game analysis i'm
like oh it should be easy wait wait a
second there's little tricks here and
just must be so frustrating to have these kind
of positions and not only to to not win it but
then to to lose it to lose it is just a knife i
mean that's just a dagger but he's better again
you've got one of those end games and i feel like
once again white is better but we've seen this
been the narrative of the match no better better
better time pressure for me hall but he finds
every single chance yeah and rook g1 just played
to defend the bishop i guess and maybe try to go
for a g5 this feels like one of these positions
where it's not clear where the punches are going
to be thrown but you just need to do something
as you were down four points here wow 14 minutes
left i mean alexi needs to start getting on
streaks he can't just win one game and then
have nihal strike back unless he needs to win two
in a row otherwise he's two and he needs to have
the lead within two points i think yes nihal
is without a doubt the favor of the bullet but
alexi has been fast he's been on form and anything
can happen in the bullet we know that but he needs
to set himself up for that if it's a four or five
point lead uh someone like neha i mean he's just
not gonna let that slip i think no he will not
and both players have had uh this kind of setup
from both colors and it is an end game where the
rook on b5 is very nice putting pressure on b2
the a4 pawn could be considered over extended but
not so easy to get to and what's happening here
this is interesting now rook takes c5 he wants to
get his knight around maybe but now he goes comes
back to b5 he ties himself to that b coupon
okay there was some kind of like knight d5
net for check stuff but there is now 95 now to
stop knight c3 maybe it should be considered
again the time in saranac's favor is up and i get
up a minute but it's like doesn't matter maybe
you should try going down a minute and see if that
helps right exactly just sit there until he's got
30 seconds he's been up a minute plenty of times
and it's not working out for him and nihil just
very sharp in these critical moments so let's see
knight d5 you mentioned in the way stop knight c3
how big of a deal is knight c3 you played knight
c3 i played rook a5 you attacked my pawn yeah and
b6 six okay that's a pretty committal move but i
suppose he's well rook d2 now the thing that that
one has to be concerned about if you need all
those pawns on the queen side of it they're just
weak they're tender but he's trying to use active
defense here ward off the immediate pressure
yeah if you're a c5 my king can actually even
consider kind of the c or mine does exactly
that all right so you can't play b5 the c5 is
hanging this is very unpleasant king e5 maybe
can you make that sound effect again no i don't
it's like this person does not exist you
know can you be five uh excuse me uh rook
don't get mated though i'm not gonna e5 king e5
king e5 yeah um that's probably a good move knight
c3 though yeah at that point you can trade knights
wait is there a mate that's a rook c4 or k5
yeah that would be a self mate good but if i
go rook d one are you playing rookie five in
kingston 66. he might be five nice check here
king c6 rook d5 oh free knight just kidding b5
check thank you for and he does that center
maybe 96 here i don't know no that's crazy
okay so knight back to c3 and so b5 no knight
b5 knight b6 oh very clever i was like beef
has to work unbelievable again he's knight b6
knight c4 is an idea the question is does he
keep the knights he's got to decide fast no
but rook a8 i mean it's even worse probably
not in rook a7 just to keep the seventh
rank defended make sure g7 h7 feel nice and
uh safe over there and well takes kc e4 he wants
to ki 3 f4 but this could be a risky end game yep
and uh well okay the pawn end game again we
talked about the smaller pawn majority g5
no g5 looks very good that's crunching
through and then the kingdom's d5 this
is winning for black it must be it is and g5
ends the game he's still and he's calculating
f3 and you get as they call them trousers and
you would go c4 and then b4 and c3 okay well
let's see how you want to go b4 are you going to
go f3 yes yeah you're right you start pushing the
pawns and then you go c4 the one thing you've got
to be careful about yeah f3c4 okay this also works
this is the conventional method and wait a second
yeah he's gonna do it gotta be careful see foreign
c3 and a3 and it was super important that
c3 attacks something because uh we'll we'll
we'll show this in another win for anyhow great
technique we'll bring up this game just to show
you a very important sequence here that after b4
check king to d3 b takes a3 would be incorrect
because when you get to this position now when
you play c4 c3 you're not actually attacking
the pawn on b2 so in the event of f3 king e3 c4 i
take and c3 doesn't threaten c takes b2 and so i
can just play king e3 and i'm in the box right
my king is just in time to uh survive this so
that would be a really bad decision easy to to do
something like that but you know taking his time
and this is i mean incredible display here
right typical pawn sacrifice that's one of the
initial end games you learn is you give
a pawn in the center and then spring free
uh another so this was a really nice finish by
nihal in another game by alexia where you're
just like is there any way to beat this guy yeah
try my best what kind of position do i need to get
how much of a time pressure do i need to put
this guy in does it matter he's going to find
chances now we have a very unbalanced position
alexi doing when he has to and we remind the
viewers that alexi a trooper for playing this
during a tournament uh he's playing the russian
higher league which is far from something
to sneeze at uh and uh he's been tremendous
here so this is certainly not a match that i
would call over he's going to try his best but
these last 10 minutes are pivotal if he wants
any chance at all of fighting back yeah and for
alexi maybe he used up a lot of his good fortune
against jeffrey because in those first three games
alexey himself said in the post-match interview
he's like i was losing i was lost and somehow he
scored two and a half to three in those games
against jeffrey and i i don't think this is
exactly the same scenario but there have been
times where nihal has just been in trouble and
yet he is the one who has just been claiming all
of the points i mean nine and a half four and
a half against a player of alexis caliber after
beating hike marty rosian by an incredible score
neil sarin is just worthy right that guy is
going to be in the speed chest championship
he keeps this up and he is not going to be an easy
out no matter which super massive face and uh he's
got a very bright future in tournament chess
as well he's incredibly what's always struck
me about him is how versatile he is he can play
so many different types of positions he's only
16 years old he's over 2600 so uh he is a force
to be reckoned with as of course is alexi sardar
uh and and it's really uh such a treat to watch
these players form and grow before our very eyes
for sure and well i'm looking at this
game donya the bivinic variation always
immensely complicated what's going on with
this b4 c3 you typically don't want to allow
that protected pawn on c3
you'd like to play a3 and start
chipping away but that doesn't seem like it's
going to happen and i like sauron's position here
well i do as well then one thing that concerns
me is of course the screen on d5 it's under the
x-ray of the bishop there's nothing that i can do
with it here that's a brave move isn't it rookie
one queen e5 is his idea or queen b6 yeah and
you can't castle king's side because this bishop
that is a problem but you could go knight t6 in
some of these positions and then you have like
crazy ideas of stacking on e6 right you can
just like bring all the forces hey i agree
with you robert this is this is not looking good
for white and at the very least for alexia draw is
heading into losing territory because you need
to start winning we keep talking about this
and you have chances here that's for sure
what's the material account white has six pawns
black hat wait it's even material wait it
is why no it's not six what's the sixth one
i'm looking at this as if they're slipping
four paw whites up three points no
that's crazy i was exactly the same well well
this h2 pawn doesn't really feel relevant yet
but in end games in particular you just start
running that pawn up the board and black's pawns
look far more menacing on b4 and cd yeah
but you can play a3 perhaps undermine them
that's true that's a useful idea so c5 wait what
whoa whoa excuse me isn't there not a rook on a8
that is not happy to see the bishop one g2 oh
it's the bishop on g2 is happy to see the row
okay so we have this f6 is hanging oh bishop e5
first okay but now what i was worried about is um
queen e4 bishop c6 so queen e4 protecting the
bishop and also lying bishop c6 with a pin
well i guess black has some okay drops
his bishop back he takes a more measured
approach maybe bishop e2 he wants to play
just castle but bishop should be seven yeah
look at that diagonal have fun castling
danya that's right right exactly in fact
cast yourself out queen c6 f3 there's
knight g4 h2 this is under attack here
but okay but knight g4 if we extend that line
knight g4 i'm going to go bishop g5 and i'm
going to threaten mate of my own oh i'm gonna play
it oh if i have f60 you're just a mean i'll throw
in bishop d4 check i have to stop you from making
it yes i'm gonna take it what are you doing here
yeah you you don't believe in
this position yeah no i don't
oh man so he's always found something though
wait you're coming back to c7 i don't know
about that though he's threatening bishop g3
i mean that's clearly the idea 13 seconds 10
seconds about to be had by nihal here we go
with this again how can you defend this if he
defends this position with seven seconds crazy
queen i mean i guess he can play queen f2 oh my
goodness oh now he's threatening me again it's me
oh my goodness and brook seat is obviously not oh
i once said again knight d5
maybe alex you should have played
because now knight d5 you could take and open up
that e file true and there's a bishop c5 checked
that you have to worry about because the knight
on d5 means that the bish 25 is not defended
once something captures c5 i'm telling you this
is unbelievable bishop g5 is another idea on f4
although that does open up the long diagonal yeah
bishop c5 oh my oh rook d6 and the wheels come off
so oh she takes everything keeping the pin
alive removing the defenders and three pawn
oh my god so precise training the queen just trade
them this is still in here phenomenal for him
and he resigns unbelievable turnaround i mean
the guy is a defensive maestro yeah he is carter
kuryakin has that nickname minister of defense but
he's the whole has something to say about that in
this match he's reminding me of grishoug honestly
playing better with no timeouts exactly he's just
waiting for his time to take down says all right
now time to turn it on and alexi played e4 in this
game by the way so now we have a martial attack
where black is down to pawn but there's plenty of
compensation especially if you're g3 look at the
light squares around white's king that's something
that you'd like to take advantage of but this
is still theoretical territory and the lead is
ballooned to six points and that is a huge huge
lead given the kind of form that nihal is in uh
what does serrano do how much time is left
in the match two minutes this might be the
last game of the three minute segment we've
been saying it all along i mean 93 by the way
93. is that not i mean rook takes e394 wins
the exchange back but remember black sacked
the pawn and he can win it back oh this is
just collapsing here yeah we're no good no
good 94 just rook takes e4 as you're suggesting
and then you you can sound better yeah you have
two bishops and yeah i mean your opponent also has
two bishops but your bishops are better developed
uh your king is safe and you you can't play
f5 now but i'm looking at king h8 f5 f4 as
an option you can repeat also rookie it also
looks good you're right yeah this is nasty
and you feel for alexi you know it's something we
talk about this you know you take blow after blow
and at some point you just reach the end of
your rope what do i have to do you know i'm
getting these positions i can't convert them and
uh you know the tilt sort of happens gradually and
uh you know at this we can celebrate the amazing
performance by siren while also sympathizing with
alexi who has put his heart on the line every one
of these matches yeah he has and he's not going to
give up even though he's down by six points and he
also happens to be the better player but he just
he must be so frustrated and like what can he do
what more can he do he needs to put away the games
where he has an advantage that obviously has been
in his control throughout the entire match but
most people they get down to their waning seconds
they just lose the game with any move that's
played nihal not one of those guys just yeah
it's incredible and and not only is he able to
find quality moves he's what impresses me is that
he's not deterred by sudden moves and time versus
normally with two seconds you don't have time to
react to something crazy but he it seems like he
spends those last two seconds and then generates
a move it's an incredible sight to behold
but we know that in the bullet there is
more than seven or eight games played so
mathematically anything is possible and neither
of these players is giving up or relaxing
yeah actually something you were just
saying is very striking it's almost as if
nihal is anticipating the unexpected and that is
so hard to train yourself to do like when you have
three seconds in your clock and there's
a full board so many different options
but to be able to expect maybe a move on the other
side of the board or one just that doesn't really
do much of anything so you also have to make a
patient move so hard to drain that kind of focus
and board vision and talents that that takes
is incredible and he possesses all of that and
more and let's see this end game is looking
good for black because after queenie e4 fe4
maybe it should be a draw but white can't punch
through his you know palm majority at all and now
we just took on a4 because the
bishop was hanging play a3 and
black as well and now a pass upon and now a bishop
end game is also going to be winning for black
and this might be another win and
that would be a seven point game
coming into the one minute segment sarnath's
got to try to save this but so draw probably
maybe oh yeah he does oh he simply works but nihal
says okay no reason to go crazy it's a six point
game and uh a miracle only a miracle is going to
save sir enough from the clutches of nihal siren
what more is there to say then nihal sarin is an
absolute monster the guy is not to be deterred
i from the very beginning of the match was
thinking hey he's getting some time trouble
sarnath thrives in those situations but it has
been all nihalsan the grandmaster teenager from
india he's such a superstar right now and he
has big sponsorship deals and he's about to
win this junior speeches championship and make
his way to the speed chest championship where
as i said dania i really think he could pull
off a first run upset there indeed i believe
he can he is incredibly talented he is delivering
on his reputation uh but he has 30 minutes of one
plus one left and so does sarna to make a miracle
happen we'll see whether that in fact occurs but
first the players are going to take a break and
so are we we'll be right back everybody stay tuned
so
and we returned ready for the bullet portion
of this match dania it looks like it's nihal
saron's match to win but there is a lot of prize
money at stake and the prizes are given by win
percentage so it's not just the winner and loser
get x amount of dollars no no no no every single
game counts and as you see here 2500 the winner
and the invitation to the speeches championship
plus the rest is split by one percentage another
2 500 so daniel quite a big payday indeed a lot at
stake and a lot of pride at stake and definitely
the speed chess championship a very coveted ticket
at stake as well uh so not only are you know they
still playing for the match and it's never over
till it's over but as you mentioned every single
game counts in terms of the prize money so we
have 30 minutes of bullet here six point lead
for me hall that's huge obviously particularly
considering how much of a beastie is in bullet
we can see already uh alexi has taken his seat
he's prepared him what did you tell yourself
if you're if you're relaxing in this situation
um nothing you hadn't you had a great run uh
second place is still a phenomenal performance so
kudos to you now you have to just move honestly i
don't know how to beat nihal sarn in bullet chest
if i did i would be somewhere much closer to his
rating but you just have to move and you have to
win immediately so you don't if you draw a game
and it takes you four minutes it's equivalent to a
loss at this point because you're down so much in
the scoreboard so you just have to move as quickly
as possible and hope that it works out for you
no sure i don't know how to beat him as well and
we've seen him put on a display in the bullet
and win the match at the bullet segment alone
uh and and i agree i mean following your
intuition is absolutely key just forcing it
out of yourself essentially and and not taking
that 30 seconds you know the critical moment
i just you know this is a lesson that if you are
not you would have hoped you've learned it earlier
in the match because now it's bullet that is
uh it is nihal's forte and we're off here 11 to 5
and we are getting a qgd a ragosan heading our way
indeed uh that's we've seen a lot of openings
here on display which i really like different
structures uh different approaches and
uh this is a very solid line for white
and one of black's ideas of course black
has the two bishops normally black goes a6
bishop d6 okay he takes on c3 that's a more modern
approach to this line uh but i've always felt like
white is slightly better in the structure he's
got that b file pressure he's got that wedge in
the center right you have uh the extra pawn right
in the center here very safe and sound there are
no useful discoveries you can move your knight to
e5 but that would have just allowed the queen to
retreat so e5 played the queen mosaic and that's
what's so nice by having the c3 e3 pawns the
center is reinforced so down here knight a5 trying
to make use of the light squares on the queen side
is black in time to seize control of them
well he's got e4 that's pretty interesting uh
and i suppose that's what the battle is going
to revolve around what is going to happen in the
center knight b3 is possible he plays it and then
c4 d5 white is definitely better i think uh even
if from a practical perspective but i do really
like what cern is doing he keeps challenging
nihal's control over the center yeah miss rook d2
rook d1 and if you take on d4 take out the rook
use that open file to advantage c4 c4 driving it
in yeah with pc on the board it's better to have
more pawns towards the center that's why the v3 c4
configuration is nice in the pure end game having
the outside pass pawn could be useful but it
takes with the bish1c4 no outside passport for you
dino this is just better pieces pretty much every
single one for white yeah beautiful outpost square
squid e5 now a4 is one thing you have to watch
out for which nihal takes care of with this move
rook a6 uh this is uh well the default queen
g5 defends the a5 pawn the rook does leave the
defile and nihal very solid going for the queen
trait he doesn't even really mind the long draws
not to suggest this is a draw lexi is the one
who has to uh prove prove the defense here in
fact how does black key yeah i don't know
if i see how it might survive this honestly
there was another tough position here i mean i'll
take on a5 right away crunches that pawn yeah and
you still have full complete control over the
d file you can't even get a rook d of rook d7
so just painful honestly indeed and now he's going
to add an attack to the mix rook d8 is a threat
queen d8 just that's a good move practicable
very practical he's up upon he can play this
for a year and he's probably winning at the end
of it yes he's the ideal set of circumstances
e4 and a light square there it goes bishop
d5 thank you for the pawn and was the king
gonna go to h4 and self mate rook d5 check is
coming oh gotta try it here's definitely g5
h5 now i would just take well no it takes bishop
h3 h5 is actually a very good move i was thinking
f3 because you don't have rook c2 but there
might be like rook a7 you know trying to get
around that one rook t4 is nice because now if you
take on g4 you walk into a pin now the b-pawn goes
and this has been a story of the defile that
won him the game he collected the puns and
it's symbolic that his rook remains on the deep
file all throughout essentially yeah kg3 now
should be good he was b5 just put he's gonna
keep pushing the pawn rook b4 is also possible
if need be b7 oh rook d8 next yep it's over and
another win for knee hall and such a smooth game
particularly for bullet he's up 20 seconds
he's winning the game and there's a resignation
32-83 so he had his rating has actually decreased
since we started the junior speeches championship
her live with that right i think he'll be okay 32
83 let's get serious here what a slacker i know
but yeah he'll be okay with losing 20 bullet
points as long as he makes his way to the sec
absolutely that's what's important
here and we have a queen's indian
i mean yeah this is this is just rough this is
rough but i like white's position in these types
of structures because he's got that pressure on
the devon but it's hard to follow through on that
black can assign all of his resources the task
of defending the pawn and if black pushes white
away rook d70 doubles things could turn around
slowly but surely yeah the only good news about
having some a6 is it could be a night a fortnight
b6 you to be careful for just think about anytime
you move upon what the consequence is and knight
of three check oh yeah he just trades in that f6
he's following the strategy of playing very solid
uh long games and not giving anything up you know
easily he's playing so much more quickly and you
may say duds bullet but he's playing much more
quickly in the bullet and seems more confident
so this is his time control he did say as much
after last match that he loves playing bullet just
a lot of fun yeah he's terrible at five-minute
chess and he's so badly there so weak obviously
it just seems like he really finds his form in
at the end of the match which is scary when
he was already up six points heading into
the quickest time control right it's it's
crazy it is absolutely crazy and 94 i guess
g4 queen f4 knight h5 oh you've queen a4
oh that's close though it's so close and
he's thinking maybe c4 first but then the
queen is the d4 square oh no stop it yeah
why do you have to be so mean yeah i'm sorry man
but actually g4 queen of four d4 if you eat then
knight h5 does trap the queen but i really like
this move because 95 oh that's that's something
that's because i guess you got to move your rook
out of the picture wait and he gets back back
huh interesting choice to go back
to f6 rook h8 now a threat so yeah
does he see a rookie shape then work h1 okay yeah
you can take take quincy check but how far are you
really getting there right not very far i think
you just have to fight your time maybe a5 maybe
d4 a fight with d4 there's also g4 possibilities
just straight along the d file black's very solid
here and he's got a bad the passer he does and
you can play g4 queen e4 things like that and
i mean earlier we would have probably said well
neil is eight seconds but we've grown so used to
excellence from him with no time on the clock
that it doesn't even seem to be a deterrent now
i wasn't even noticing it honestly right exactly
so d3 three queen takes d5 in rook t3 there was no
discovery he's going to be down upon here i think
but it's not easy to get to that pawn if you go
kiki 2 you go you run into 94 knight g4 king e2
yeah something oh now if you take there's a pork
at the end of it very important so do you start
with 92 or something then there's knight g4 check
and knight back that's right oh and black wins oh
my god oh you black was winning there was a king
what am i saying like this i mean this is an extra
pawn for white so at least alexa can play this out
ah he's very tied down though he is
this good yeah knight c3 i guess net h1
wow that's a hilarious move these this is gonna
be a race it's anybody's game honestly i mean
these races it doesn't matter who's up upon
it's about the quality of the past one right
and one pawn does move faster than two because
you're right two together yeah but wait here two
yeah that's that's not a good transformation
and white should be winning king d2 that way
you can try play you can't play rook v6 it was
rookie h2 check but now the pawns are going b5 a4
etcetera and the king is close enough to the
f-bomb right f3 this is a mistake wait a minute
he might be losing here if he is not careful you
have to give a bunch of checks yeah but the king
just stops the the rook from coming to the eighth
ring so the black king will go back and forth
king e3 not possible f2 that's a good move though
but he goes rook before something like that so
roxy won rook f1 and then after rookie for those
kings oh you guessed work at five king c3 qc3
yeah but now the king approaches and this is one
of those theoretical end games yeah i should be
winning king rotation yeah b6 at some point
simply now king c5 king b5 and keep marching
up here this has been known since the 17th
century quite literally you build a bridge and
here it comes king a7 king b6 king c6 this never
gets old there's a certain elegance to this uh
lucina plan that always you know entices me every
time i see it i'm going to pull up that last game
for half a second because i want to show something
you know what i would do expecting my opponent i'm
losing right i know i'm lost i've played rook
c7 hoping for the pre-movement rook before
right that way i can take your absolutely silly
but you know these are just little bullet tricks
that should not work out i just think that you
have to try something i gotta try what you gotta
try yep and uh that was a great game my sir
and i mean he's staying calm i don't think
he's gotten massively tilted or anything of that
sword i mean of course he got upset i think there
are a couple of games where he was under the
influence of those games he failed to win
uh but by and large he's remained level-headed
it's just been nehal's incredible form that has
carried the match yeah plus six 20 minutes to go
technically there's an outside shot that you can
win six in a row and tie it but if we're being
realistic nihal just the monster of all monsters
here and what's going on in this game black people
should have six as possible well black is up so
much time yo chest 12 seconds i don't think nihal
has been down on time ever in this match actually
first try very good integration i
mean got to work on that so let's see
now white is down 20 seconds and there's a lot
of trouble here black has the bishop queen h7
king but where do you go from here because
queen g okay but now night of night back tonight
nine of five fighter five oh no you didn't yes
i did nothing that was so cool that was winning
wasn't it this also looks really good though yeah
it does d5 crunch and d6 oh my gosh g6 not only
takes away the score of thrones d7 forking your
rooks yup 97 oh yeah yeah then d6 is you mentioned
98 probably you have to try but then d6 again
that's exactly what you said oh my goodness hm8
can't stop both d67 or d6 you've got to try to
trap the queen somehow and go bishop takes that
three queen eight oh wow that's interesting
you could actually take on e7 and take on
f3 i think that's a nemo kind of thing to do
you can play queen of shape bishop h7 queen g8
mate oh that's also a ufo thing to do that's a
robert hess thing to do ouch ouch ouch i rub my
my itchy nose and just there's nothing more
you can say about this just it's a demolition
absolute demolition and we have a question that
i'm gonna air out and put you on the spot robert
from our again our amazing producer uh and
our entire production team bick if you're down
this much in a match how you know sort of
quote-unquote dirty do you get do you left
someone do you go for the bishop h6 trick uh is
that totally frowned upon or is there some sense
to just doing that when you're this losing in a
match yeah i mean who as long as you're trying to
get back on the scoreboard like who cares how you
do it most times doesn't cost you the game so it
um you know it won't work and you look silly
but no i'm serious that's right if you do
something that's just not if you play if you
play bishop takes c4 hoping for some pre-move
and they don't pre-move and they just take your
bishop then you look like the fool but if you
play bishop c4 and they make some other move
then you look really smart so that's really
the two ends of that and personally when i i don't
really like bullet regardless but if i'm playing
and somebody does that it really ticks me off
but then i'm just like i mean what they didn't do
anything wrong they just did something silly and i
fell for it i used to take it very personally and
get very mad uh but but you know you realize that
it's the people don't always have this agenda of
you know deeply disrespecting people just going
for the win and uh it's it's not very nice but
at the end of the day you know you just don't
pre-move you know it's you're getting a chance
to win the game very fast it's on you that
you've decided to pre-move at the end of the
day your opponent doesn't owe it to you to be nice
on the chessboard no he doesn't so what's going on
with sarina's connection it feels like yeah he
frequently had one or two bars in this game and
he might just lose on time because
yeah 95 95 c4 and then i comes into d3
and uh even without the time disparity
yeah 58 seconds to two seconds look at
this yeah the internet is not serna's
friend here and neither is the position
no and let's see queen h5 through knight f3 so
the king is going back and forth a little bit
and he just repeats rook d6 by the way is an
interesting idea he's just going to drop on
time isn't he rook d6 and 94 and he loses on time
that's brutal and indeed the connection worsening
uh at the worst possible time during the bullet
he's got that one bar and that's not helping him
helping things for alexi yep and was it now seven
eight points wow 14 to six after 20 games played
yeah and unfortunately for lexi it's just getting
worse with his connection seemingly yeah we remind
people just joining that alexi is not playing
from home he's playing from a hotel room uh he's
playing an over the board tournament right now
so huge kudos to alexi for nonetheless finding
the time to play the match uh that's you know
it could have easily said you know we demanded
a reschedule but uh really a classy classy guy
and very modest we've seen him in the interviews
uh both of them really so absolutely and for
neal he adjusted his schedule to play earlier
than expected and it's certainly panning
out for him in this matchup and for alexi we
he's got a few games bullet left and then he'll
be playing the russian higher league where
of course we wish him uh the best of luck in
that event it's gonna be such a tough event
with all the not just top russian players
but players flying for their yeah you know
um actually no it is just russia right the
russian higher league i think yeah i was thinking
yeah because sometimes in the leagues uh
you can have foreign players wouldn't take
say five then by the way with you mr pawn oops
oh there's bishop before at the end of that oh
that's cool but this looks still very good
he's driving in the pond that's like a london
dream queen to v2 look at the piece shifting
around v6 is a good move under mining the one
and now we don't have a symmetrical pawn structure
because a versus b but i think that if you win the
b you lose the a and vice versa so it's going to
be tough to prove an advantage here it is and uh
for new hall it's all about you know playing solid
chess bleeding out the clock at this point there
are 15 minutes below 15 minutes left in the match
this is we remind you they are also playing for oh
wait bishop f591 oh but then bishop before
maybe you're okay yeah you sneaky sneaky guy
he just takes on a5 instead um and there is
prize money tied up in the actual results so
every game matters true knight e5 maybe i mean
the position is just better for what because the
pawn structure black has some current activity
but you need to keep d5 f5 all defending and now
jump around knight c5 roxy one to follow as well
i don't c2 has to be watched over queen a7 looks
good oh going after f7 they're going queen to
d7 perhaps 57's next 27 is coming oh he goes
to a4 springs it up here it's hard to even
make okay there here comes 27. can't stop it
bishop c7 is a really nice move that's pain that's
just it is flat out pain and bishop d6 i mean
it's it's literally just target
practice here it's mowing down the pawns
knight d7 is also good oh it just takes 94
97 anything knight f6 another possible six
this is no fun i mean he makes it look easy i
that expression is overused and it's a huge cliche
but he makes it look easy he does he just checked
me with the guy queen g7 queen g4 is made yup
that's that's just incredible what is happening
like it's 15 to 6 and there's still just under
13 minutes left yeah i mean it's one feels for
alexi when you're taking this sort of a beating
you know you just look at the match clock
all right all right when will this end uh and
it's i mean it's incredible really
what whitney hall's doing just
i wish i had the words to describe what's
happening yeah lexi against sam sevien and
that was that game assumed that match came down
to the final game where sevien actually had a
winning position but alexi fended him off and
won that game and one by two i think it's jeffrey
alexey was dominant on the scoreboard in both the
five and the three minute time segment and then
jeffrey almost you know he's in the version
making a real comeback in the bullet but he
didn't have enough time he ended up losing
by uh three games so i'm not mistaken
so alexia has proven himself to be a formidable
opponent but somehow nihal is just next level
right now yeah he is every time to troll
every position i impossible to bring down
in bad positions ruthless in good positions
tricky in equal positions it just i mean
it's been a force just to be reckoned with here
and uh you know nobody likes to see a beating
and i think it's important to again as i said
keep two things in mind here on the one hand to
truly uh celebrate and and sort of uh appreciate
the incredible strength of nihal and at the same
time to uh congratulate alexi on an amazing uh on
his amazing play throughout the tournament and to
sympathize with him you know it's never easy to
to be on the receiving end of this kind of beating
no certainly not he can score a couple of wins
down the stretch to make himself feel a little
bit better not too much but ninety nine six
ninety seven five so there's more tactics
over there yeah just trying to sit on the position
but somehow nihilism yeah king g7 he's going to
twist his pieces around he's going to perform some
gymnastics and he's going to be better in like
five hours yeah he's uh playing devilish defense
which i guess is only fitting because apparently
we had a quote from nihal before the match and
we interviewed him well we did but somebody
did and he said his friends call him the
devil sometimes and i think we see why
and he's slaughtered is what it is his
position isn't very good though right now
no but that hasn't stopped him
that's true it certainly has not
um he's got his rook on e6 is a good defender
he's keeping his 98 to stop any kind of knight f6
but he's very much tied down here you can't
play c6 that drops b6 oh and a nice idea
well actually h4 king h3 just inching in but
you got to be careful when you're in 97.97
yeah 97 and it finds it and whether where
there is a knight there is trouble but
this is queen e7 knight she's seven six e6 drives
the pawn in queen g5 though queen e fight f5 oh my
goodness that's all very close yeah you get you
thankfully get the queen because otherwise this
little fork here would have been alexa gets this
one faster yep the queen takes up five queen e3 so
queen me queen b2 to the last drop of blood every
game that is why do you bring this king up to c2
okay nice try that knight if i was smart if there
was one less attacker on e7 that would have been
more effective yeah and alexi just says all right
i'm getting a king and i'm getting checkmate
and um yeah yeah for alexi he just will try
to get a couple more his bullet rating is
30 39 even notice that because he's looking but
32 in front of nihal's rating but alexa clearly
no no beginner when it comes to their is
incredible again that really only only hikaro can
can compete with uh you mean i would say both of
them are so incredibly strong uh and uh yeah this
is this has been a treat to watch these players 95
nihal jumping on ahead here the opening yeah the
queens are coming off so it looks like shouldn't
be too big of an advantage for either side but
there's plenty of life left if the queens are
not traded and black can even play queen eight
if you're not careful so that's why the queens
came off right knight t3 here creating that pin
against the bishop this might fizzle out if alexi
is able to ward off the immediate initiative
and before just bishop moves back to d6
okay not that big a deal [ __ ] should be
five rookies seven this should be five could be
nasty because rookie seven will take the bishop
okay definitely better with the two bishops
yeah yeah for sure these bishops are great
so and bishop moving well then i might find
the bishop that rook and you want you got to
be careful about rookie eight how do you wait five
three f three oh and five mississippi five oh oh
you defend the rook oh so that's gonna drop to
g3 to keep the rook defended here it could have
gone d2 as well but now c5 is really hanging
and i don't know if sorry not has a move here
well you get the e file that's what's important
here oh and he also attacks the knight then that's
a that's a devastating pin rook d8 rook takes
c5 thank you yep and that's in exchange and rook
takes takes boom yeah back ranker there's
the background mate which is music capture
it's over another smooth display by knee hall
who's not taking the foot off the gas pedal
yeah yeah in these situations you know it's not
easy to say anything you know it's it's match
has been decided they're playing for some prize
money rook takes c4 by the way wins the game
on the spot and he finds it uh but i'm just sad
this is coming too now this has been and i'm sure
we'll talk about it in the end robert but what an
event this has been and what a match this has been
yeah it's a little strange it feels like
we were so spoiled earlier in the bracket
and there were many close matchups coming down to
the absolute wire for example nihal against anton
smirnov was super close uh saranac versus sevien
was really as close as he gets and then in the
70s in the finals somehow instead of the matches
getting more competitive they've almost become
less competitive yeah that just happens sometimes
you know because the players are in different
frames of mind uh you never know what's going
to happen and the great thing about the gscc
is it's not like one of those things where you
have a round of 32 and there's clear favorites
i think one of the the you know the magic of
this event um apart from the players themselves
where the strengths of the players always
being close even in the opening matches
anything can happen in any match so we were on
the edge of our seats essentially every single
match yes that's the case and i mean all credit
should go to nihal because in the first matches
andrew tank he looked very mighty then against
anton smirnov we're like wait this guy is actually
very beatable and he was losing in the five-minute
portion of smirnoff he was even losing after the
end of the three minute if i'm not mistaken to
smear it off and then the bullet is where he
decided to you know that was the time to shine
and after that so i guess not even just have it
with the exception of that match it hasn't
looked close in his other badges so nihal
something about smirnoff style was tough for nihal
otherwise he has just been an absolute just demon
and that's why his friends call him that and and
it's yeah one gets the sense the confidence level
and just the ability to play all of these types of
positions with time pressure it's it's the set of
skills being as well-rounded as as it is i mean
he's i think definitely going to be above 2700
uh he's you know you can just sense the talent and
the the maturity level and the versatility um and
uh he is the very well deserved going to
be the very well-deserved winner of the
jscc a tournament that is going to be
fascinating for years and years to come robert
and with the addition of the four qualifiers
from the speeches championship grand prix and
vladimir putin say you know getting second place
in the super swiss but because the car nakamura
is already qualified we have some players who um
in that ballpark of neil siren right there's very
strong players who may not be 2750 plus fide
so it i'm very curious who nihal's first round
matchup will be because some players are much more
difficult than others especially stylistically but
i do think that nihal i've said this throughout
the match today he has a chance no matter who
he faces anybody i do believe he does not want to
face hikaru nakamura i don't know why he's pretty
easy to pretty easy opponent but no i mean he's
got a chance against anybody particularly if he
displays the same kind of confidence uh and and
ability to survive and thrive in time pressure
but uh that's going to be an incredible event
in its own right this format there's something
about this format whether it was the i am not a
gm whether it was the jscc the scc it brings out
not only the best in players but it just makes
it so competitive it makes it so fun to watch
you get all of the time control showcased and you
get a little bit of everything which is awesome
indeed indeed and three minutes left of the
jscc we know that nihal sarn is the champion
uh now this is just a formality at this
point and will he be able to take this
game is king is far more active there's rookie
two check that you have to keep an eye on so
right here it comes that king needs to be on c3
not on g3 rook f3 forces the game to the second
rank maybe you chase the knight away now i don't
know okay knight d7 hitting v6 but the rook yeah
comes back in defense despite the symmetrical pawn
structure it's a very unbalanced position the fact
that black's king is so far it really hurts him in
relation to the pawns but he chases the night away
from the position of the knights of the dancing
it's funny don you see it hurts him with relation
to the pawns totally agree but it helps him if you
keep the rooks on the board and create an attack
like king f2 king e290 yeah it can walk in all
of a sudden so i have to be a bit careful here
here comes the king and white's king inches inches
further into its little cave there on a3 but
that's going to be smoked out with a knight
so he comes back rookie 6 again the dance
knight e3 and that you called it king e2
that's going to happen all of a sudden the
attack is going to be made it could be a quick
mating net bikini two is rookie's two checks
and so alexi finding ways king e2 now sliding
the king in rook h6 i would play rook d1 coming
oh here we go here's rook d1 that's exactly
what you called where exactly is the knight
this is amazing oh my gosh united 192 mate
knight f192's mate oh my god oh this is
incredible how oh my that ness was that is the
tuple exclamation mark on top i'm pulling up
that board that is what is that that was sick
king c2 thinking that you're going after the
b-pawn but it's all about mating this king
the king has no safe squares after knight b6
93 that's a pawn need a knight end game oh my
god you found that instantly well the king would
only have one escape square after you pushed the
pawns incredible geometry incredible and 92
made what a final position i mean that's the
absolutely this is just illegal i mean this is
just ridiculous at this point and oh wait what's
happening here the bishop one before he just lost
the bishop maybe he's not even stopping he's just
stepping on that gas pedal 97 i guess is fine for
luck though right because if knight takes e7 you
can always take on c3 but now queen before but
that was just something out of a study yeah that
was that was wonderful castle queen stuff i think
for white now yeah that that was just unbelievable
94 oh gosh here it comes
now what's particularly impressive is how he
hasn't let up and it's not out of uh i'm not
saying this to imply that he should have he's he's
just displaying the same exquisite level of play
uh even in the bullet even though obviously the
match has been decided for quite a while now
what a beast like they're i'll be honest
there were moments where i was kind of like
it felt like sarna should have more points and
you know nihal was really spent too much time
yeah in the earlier segments but when i see
that night checkmate i forget about all of
that past stuff and i'm sorry oh you do yeah
this guy's just you're you realize you're at
that point nine of five is coming it's weird
six two in the presence of greatness and this
is going to be the last game of the segment and
the last game of the match end of the entire
tournament what will the last move be of the
tournaments uh resignation because knight at
five you can't play queen f6 96 check wins
the queen and here comes queen h6 otherwise
and rook takes that f5 rook g5
you might have a rook stack here
yes mate it's made in a fitting conclusion
to an unbelievable run by niho sarin and
such an impressive run of
course by alexis serrano as well
rook takes the it was made in two this is also
fine bishop h saw no i don't do that to make so
got to alexi there but it was winning anyway 18
to 7 the final score as nihal seren wins the jscc
at performance for the ages robert yeah he
saved his best for last and niall sarin just
cruised honestly to the championship what a what
a worthy winner he is the junior speed chess
championship you hear the word junior but their
age belies their strength all of these players are
exceptional they are world-class players and nihal
sarin he is just mesmerizing to watch absolutely
just no words to describe some of these
performances and obviously a huge congratulations
also to alexis sarna the bright young star from
russia who will now play the russian higher league
he uh played fantastic uh not only in this
match but across the board but succumbing to
the uh just the wizardry of the devil neil
sarin and for alexi he bows out of the jscc
in the final match and i believe it's his last
time able to play because he's 20 which means he
turns 21 he ages out and for nihal he'll have
many more opportunities well perhaps by next
year he'll just qualify scc directly and we are
going to take a break we want to get nihal sarn
in on the call so that we we can interview
him hear his thoughts and hey maybe he'll
just be smiling because he has won a place in the
speeches championship we'll be right back for the
interview from the junior speechless championship
match brought to you by chess.com at chestnut.com
and we are joined by the jscc champion nihal
sarin and i have so many questions to ask
you but i'll start with this one there are many
great moments by you in this match but have you
ever checkmated somebody with a knight in two
pawns against a knight in two pawns like that
yeah that was a very strange one and it just
came by excellent of course i don't calculate but
when i played knight f1 i saw that
i could just remove knight detention
congratulations that was a fantastic performance
all around uh one thing that was particularly
impressive was your ability to not only survive
in acute time pressure but also thrive and win
a lot of games with two one second on the clock
do you practice that directly do you feel like
what's the sort of secret there what do you
do to keep yourself calm and what do you do
to develop that ability um i think it's just by
playing a lot of bullets and especially i played
quite a lot of ten plus one like ten seconds
yeah also played quite a lot there i think
yeah yeah nothing can attest to your wizardry
there yeah for sure and i mean nihal you just won
yourself a payday but i think more importantly
for you as a competitor you earned your entrance
into the speed chess championship is there any
super grand master that you would particularly
want to play i mean we don't know what the field
is going to be yet but who's your dream parent
i know it's slate for you i have just one
more question looking back at the jscc and
your performance what moment will you was it
97 mate what was your most memorable match
or your most memorable moment that powered you
through to the final and to victory oh which
knight this one made right well the one the one
that you just put on the board knight 92 sorry 92
yeah maybe this one was the best i don't remember
anything well i i have another question for you
nihal um you know your matchup against anton
smirnov was your closest one do you think having
that really tough matchup early helped you because
after that the matches went completely your way so
it seemed like you actually got better the deeper
into the tournament you went yeah maybe like
that was a very tough match and yeah then
i was very happy to pull through so maybe
that energy guide me through them well i mean
we have nothing else to say but congratulations
there were so many people rooting for you so uh
you have a lot of fans out there i'm sure you've
made many more today and we just look forward
to seeing you continue to shine and well you're
going to be the speed chess championship
so that's super exciting congratulations
thank you well that is your junior speed chess
champion nihal sarin chess goals predictions
they were correct in the sense that nihal was the
champion hard to bet against that guy honestly
just how strong he was 18 to seven in the final
daniel what a performance absolutely amazing his
moves do the talking he's also confident and yet
he's humble and very mature and it's always a
pleasure to watch someone like that and his moves
really did a lot of talking today in his previous
matches this was a performance for the ages this
was an incredible display of brilliance in all
areas and what an incredible run this was by me
halsarn he is just an absolute beast and he is one
of the qualifiers for the speed chess championship
which has a hundred thousand dollar prize fund we
saw vladimir putin say have qualified via the
speedchest super swiss uh there will be the
bullet chess championship and an sec invitational
where people can earn their spot the placements i
think are set as well from the sec grand prix
maybe i i didn't actually look to see you know
who's there but i know nordie back abusive tarot
hike marty rossian were doing extremely well so
we'll round it out i'm sure they'll be mentioned
shortly but today it's all about nihal sarin the
teenager from india a superstar just he really
did achieve excellence throughout the jscc
we just have to congratulate him i i really don't
know how else we can compliment the guy because as
you said his actions spoke louder than any words
we could say absolutely they do and india has been
a chess powerhouse putting out tons of talented
young players but nihal might be the star that
shines brightest and he just confirmed that today
he's got such a bright future ahead of him he's
you see his play you think he's been around for
a while but then you look and he's only 16 years
old he's got so many more years of incredible
chess ahead of him what a performance and what
a tournament this was really a privilege and a
treat uh to have had quartzite seats uh to these
displays of brilliance yeah seriously nihal sarin
you can just you know that this guy he's already
amazing but you're going to keep an eye out
because he's only going to ascend from here and
for alexis sarina it might be his last opportunity
in the jscc but we're not done hearing from him
either we're absolutely super strong he got
through these tough pairing after tough pairing
yes of panko samsevi and jeffrey john just to make
it to the final that's an achievement in and of
itself so we should congratulate him i know it's
not the way he wanted to end his tournament but he
has a lot to be proud of as well well absolutely
there are a lot of mvps nihal the mvp but
um close well i wouldn't even say close behind
another mvp grandmaster robert has he wasn't
a participant but uh he made it better for me
oh wait he's i'm commenting with him right now
i shouldn't refer to him in the third person but
this was such a treat to watch and robert as usual
it's been an absolute pleasure i'm
sad that this is coming to an end
but it was amazing you know uh it is quite sad
that this event is over i could do so many more of
these matches with you dania it's been so fun and
you know before we sign off we'd be remiss not to
thank everybody who continues to tune in whether
you've been watching on twitch youtube chess
tv we are so appreciative of all of you you make
these matches even more fun for us and i know the
players are personally thankful for your support
because they can't read your messages during their
streams but they feel it it energizes them so
thank you so much to our producer bick who's
been with us the entire way doing an amazing
job got to thank him and to the whole team at
chess.com and chesskid.com for sponsoring this
event it makes it possible so on that note we're
going to sign off it's been real everybody enjoy
your days stay safe and happy chessing bye bye
so
do
you